wanna be happy build a life not just a
business hey it's evan carmichael and
this channel was created to help you
overcome the number one challenge that
is holding you back a lack of belief in
yourself you watch these videos because
you know there's something more inside
you too you've got michael jordan level
genius at something so today let's live
your best believe life and get some
incredible motivation from the one and
only dr joe dispenza
enjoy
if you could give everyone in the world
an experiment to do for 30 days or one
activity that they'd have to do every
day for 30 days what would it be oh i
would ask them to take out a piece of
paper and write down every thought
that they've been thinking that standing
in the way between their future and and
where they are
to write down every habit or behavior
even how they speak that stops them from
becoming the person that is healthy
wealthy or free and then to begin to
recognize the emotions
that keep them in the same state of
being every single day and become so
conscious of those thoughts behaviors
and emotions that they wouldn't let any
of them slip by unnoticed by them then i
would have them write down the thoughts
they do on a fire and wire in their
brain i would have them write down what
the behaviors look like of a great
person that they wanted to become
and i would have them practice thinking
about it and practice rehearsing it and
then i would say to them
what emotions would you feel when your
future happened because you have to
teach your body emotionally what that
future feels like before it happens and
every day if you practice that
diligently and sincerely and just become
conscious of who you no longer want to
be and keep becoming conscious of who
you do want to be
you should begin to see evidence in your
life and when it comes in a way that you
least expect
that surprises you and leaves no doubt
that it's come from a greater mind then
you'll be inspired to do it again and
now we believe we're more the creators
of our lives and less of the victims of
our lives if your brain is a record of
the past
and you are living by the same emotions
that have defined you
for the last 10 years
and you keep thinking the same thoughts
that make the same chemicals and those
same chemicals drive the same thoughts
then your body
as the unconscious mind
does not know the difference between an
actual experience in your life that
creates an emotion and an emotion that
you're creating by thought alone
and so your body is believing it's in
the same past experience
24 hours a day seven days a week
365 days a year
and your body is programmed into the
past
and you can create a new future
holding on to the emotions of the past
how many people understand what i'm
talking about
so then
when you react
to someone or something in your life
you have a choice
that when an event changes how you feel
there's a chemical change that's taking
place in your body
and most people don't think they can
control their emotional reactions
and so then when you react to some
co-worker
or some relative
or somebody in traffic
the moment you react emotionally you are
altered chemically
and if you don't know how to control
your emotional reaction after that event
and you allow those emotions to linger
for hours or days
you know what that's called
that's called a mood
what's wrong with you
oh i'm in a mood
really
why are you in a mood
well this thing happened to me four days
ago
and i'm having one long emotional
reaction
and if you keep that same refractory
period going on for weeks or months
that's called a temperament
hey
why is she so angry i don't know
why are you so angry why are you so
bitter
why are you so enchilada
[Music]
because i had this experience
seven months ago
and i
memorizing my emotional reaction
and if you keep that same refractory
period going on for years on end
that's called a personality trait
and people wear their emotions on their
sleeve
and that's who they think they are
and they will talk about the past to
validate why they're not creating the
life that they want
so then if you wake up in the morning
mexico city
and you are not being defined by a
vision that's bigger than you
and it doesn't get you out of bed and
inspire you into possibility
and you get up
living from the old hardware of the past
and the old emotions stored in your body
do you know what's going to happen to
you
you're going to wake up and you're going
to open your eyes
and you're going to see the same people
and go to the same places and do the
exact same thing at the exact same time
and the moment you open your eyes
all of a sudden now it's your external
environment that's controlling how you
think and feel
because you have a neurological network
in your brain for every person you know
every place that you go everything that
you own everything that you do
and the moment you open your eyes and
you see the same people and go to the
same places and do the exact same thing
at the exact same time it's your
external environment that's turning on
different circuits in your brain
causing you to think equal to everything
that you know
and you told me you believe that your
thoughts have something to do with your
destiny
and as long as your thinking equal to
your environment
you keep creating the same life
to change
to truly change is to think greater than
your environment
to think greater than the circumstances
in your life to think greater than the
conditions in your world and every great
person in history knew this
whether it was mahatma gandhi martin
luther king the wright brothers joan of
arc
they all had a vision if you're alive in
this world and you haven't been
experiencing the quickening i mean i
mean
you know i said to uh
someone the other day
the day where you end your day and feel
complete because you finished all your
work you'll never have that then you
know there's always more emails and more
things to check right so the demand has
has has pressed us into this crazy realm
of
uh of of um
multitasking
and i think that
you start shifting where you place your
attention is where you place your energy
so if you're shifting your attention all
over the board your energy is scattered
yeah so then when you start
disconnecting from everybody your boss
your co-worker you know the news uh your
cell phone your computer and you start
going this way
i think it's uh into the present moment
then of where you place your attention
is where you place your energy and
you're truly in the present moment
you've got a lot of energy to execute
you've got to let that energy to use and
you want to be able to do that eyes open
the more scattered your energy the less
you have to focus on pushing one thing
forward that's why people's dreams don't
happen because they're scattered
there's no look look if you keep putting
your attention on some future experience
that you are imagining with your mind
your body is going to follow your mind
right there because that's where your
energy is but if you're putting your
attention on everything known in your
life the shower the coffee maker you
know
the toilet and your body's following
your mind every day to the known but we
want your body to follow your mind to
the unknown right enough people get to
doing that
and you could
do better in creating things in your
life that we see this wealthy people in
our work that have focused on wealth
some of them living in the back seat of
their car some of them bankrupt that now
have multi-million dollar companies what
do you think they want to do with that
money
they want to give it away yeah give it
back let me tell you why not because of
any other reason is that they now know
that they create more right but why why
if you're abundant why abundance to me
has changed abundance means i have more
than i need like way more than i need so
if i have way more than i need and i
know how to create it
then take it i'll create more of it so
now you're no longer holding on in
scarcity
you're making a difference so wealthy
people that have created a lot of wealth
in this work they want to give back they
want to make a difference and i think
that that's how we're innately wired i
think we're all innately wired to care
for one another to make a difference in
the living organism our living organism
our community we heal one another that's
what we do right we inform one another
we encourage one another we support one
another
we shine for one another not to outshine
another person to shine to show them if
they can shine and that's that to me is
super healthy so then i'm i'm applauding
your success because i want you to
succeed because you're telling me that
if you can do it i can do it so so
there's no longer any separation i think
that's hopeful for the world then you
start celebrating diversity then you're
like wow you're way different than me i
want to i want to study you because i
want to bring that into who i'm becoming
what are the things that
disturb or
disconnect our awakening and connection
to the divine a lot of times when people
they hit that point they try to
reproduce it the same way as we talked
about and you can't yeah you can't do it
the same way because that's redundancy
but also many times
we have the experience and we start to
try
and because trying is matter trying to
change matter and and so we're forcing
we're controlling we're predicting and
and then the uh and when we do that then
of course we're in separation and we're
waiting for the event to happen to feel
the emotion right and
i've done that long enough and it's
actually we have to lay down
the very thing we used our whole life to
get what we want for something greater
to occur and it takes practice of
surrender right
so
that's one element i also think that our
response is emotionally
like
let's just say that a person gets
connected to the future they get
connected to the energy their future
they feel it it's really great and then
they start their day and then two hours
later they're they're feeling something
else because some person or some
circumstance altered their state well
they just disconnected from the energy
of the future and now they're back to
the energy of the past don't expect
anything to change in your life because
then work that way
so then
then when they get back to that old self
again then they say what's wrong with me
i failed they didn't do it right no
that's all the program you show up again
and you go after it again so familiar
feelings uh cause us
to no longer see through the lens of the
future we're seeing through the lens of
the past and
and we color reality that way so
um
i think i think familiar emotions uh get
in the way as well and then of course
there's always belief
and a belief is just a thought you keep
thinking over and over again until you
hardwired in your brain and all beliefs
are based on past experience a person
has an experience the stronger the
emotion they have from that circumstance
the more they pay attention to the cause
and the brain freezes a frame takes a
snapshot and that's called the memory
the moment they draw a conclusion about
that experience they'll think
neurologically within those circuits and
they'll feel chemically within the
boundaries of emotion thinking and
feeling thinking and feeling
belief becomes an unconscious or
subconscious state of being they don't
most people don't even know they have
beliefs about things about god about
relationships about money because it's
it's not a conscious thing it's a
subconscious thing yeah so in order to
change a belief or a perception
about yourself and your life
you got to go all in
it's not like you go 50 in you got to go
all in you got to make a decision
with such firm intention
that the amplitude of that decision
carries a level of energy
that causes the body to respond to the
mind that the choice that you make
becomes a moment in time you'll never
forget and you would say i remember the
moment
i made up my mind to change and the
stronger the emotion you feel the more
you'll pay attention to the decision and
that's a huge stone you drop in the
quantum field big splash big waves
you think
60 to 70 000 thoughts
in one day
out of those 60 to 70 000 thoughts that
you think in one day 90
of those thoughts
are the same thoughts
as the day before
so if you believe that your thoughts
somehow are connected to your life
then the same thoughts always lead to
the same choices
the same choices always lead to the same
behaviors
the same behaviors create the same
experiences
and the same experiences produce the
same emotions
and those very same emotions drive the
very same thoughts
and your biology
your neural circuitry your
neurochemistry your neural hormones
and even your genetic expression
is equal to how you think
how you act and how you feel
and how you think how you act and how
you feel is called your personality
and your personality creates your
personal reality
that's it
so then if you wanted to create a new
personal reality
a new life
then you would have to start thinking
about what you've been thinking about
and change it
you would have to become aware of your
unconscious thoughts and observe them
you would have to pay attention to your
automatic habits and behaviors and
modify them
and you would have to look at the
emotions you live by every single day
that are connected to your past
and decide if those emotions belong in
your future
you see most people try to create a new
personal reality
as the same personality and it doesn't
work
you literally have to become someone
else i believe in free will i would
never tell anybody what to believe like
politically or
socially or whatever
i want to provide them the tools and
give them the free will to create life
however they want and believe whatever
they want that's totally cool with me
so those people then
that
want to be healed
and they live in fear
that fear has to be addressed i mean and
it's not easy because it's
hardwired deep in the limbic brain it's
just a safety net it's a mechanism so
then imagine being in the unknown
the instinct in the unknown is it's a
scary place
wow imagine not having a body and we
practice lingering without a body in in
in an infinite space and without a name
without a face without a culture without
a job without a social security number
without a disease without a diet just as
an awareness you you practice that
you're going to be comfortable in the
unknown you're going to relax more into
it that's going against
thousands of years
of programming and the people who
actually overcome their fear
and they trade it for gratitude their
immune system gets stronger their genes
have regulated i mean there's just a
host of uh everything their brain
changes their heart rate variability
they feel differently and it's it's
being measured and and some of these
people uh we're measuring this now in
our in our events with with reputable
scientists and
universities they're they're
shocked
at what they're witnessing on a cellular
level on a brain level on a heart level
they cannot believe
the capacity of the body i just was i
just got an email today of assign one of
our scientists said i ran this
three times
the virus
that we exposed the cell to and advanced
meditators does not enter the cell it's
outside the cell it will a virus in
novice meditators some of it's in the
cell some of it's outside controls all
the viruses in the cell there's an
immunity so when the person's less
reactionary to their environment
there's less of response that weakens
them they're less of a victim to their
environment then they're less of a
victim to their environment
large scale small scale the body has a
greater immunity to whatever it is then
if you said well listen i'm not gonna
wait for my healing
to feel gratitude i'm not gonna wait for
my new relationship to feel love
i'm gonna actually teach my body
emotionally
what that future feels like before it
happens now this is a big turnaround for
a lot of people because we're so reliant
on the outer world to change our inner
world right we're waiting and perspiring
and waiting is not creating i mean
period and when people are they could
have the greatest intentions in the
world
but if they don't combine that with an
elevated emotion there's no signal
because the elevated emotion is the
carrier it's the energy that carries the
thought
so then
when we're in separation in lack waiting
for our wealth to feel abundance we're
basically living our whole life in pain
right
so then if you reason this and a person
can get up from their meditation and
they literally feel differently
and they're feeling the emotions of
their future before it happens this is
turning the
the whole process around
they can't be looking for why would they
be looking for it if they felt like it
there it already happened now there's no
separation now this is
when those serendipities and
coincidences and opportunities begin to
show up in people's lives so it's work
but then when they start seeing the
experience in their life
all of a sudden they start believing
they're more of the creator of their
life yeah and less of the victim of
their life community
becomes the side effect because because
with a community of like-minded like
like ant similar energy of people
uh everybody understands they get one
another you know you you communities
tends to be the thing now that in terms
of our
uh social media and the feedback we're
getting
everybody wants more community because
you get a you get a thousand people an
audience and their energy is
synchronized now you're looking at
something so much bigger we're just
going to measure this i just talked to a
researcher yesterday
we're going to measure
a thousand people when they reach that
synchronized moment when they're we can
we know that the entire
social coherence in the room is orderly
then if you're producing a ambient
coherent magnetic field in your heart
and
you're tuning into a thought or an
intent and you got a thousand people
doing that and your energy is going to
start interfering and co-mingling with
the person that's next to you when that
energy starts to synchronize
it's going to produce a bigger wave the
higher the amplitude the higher the wave
the more energy there is so now you have
one mind and one heart and now when it
comes to healing others and we've done
the research on this now and we're
collecting the data that we're teaching
people how to administer
a change in energy in the person that's
laying there because it's not matter
that emits a field that's the wrong way
to think about it it's the field that
creates matter
you change the field you change matter
you're not it's not your job to change
the tumor the tumor is the illusion it's
the pattern in the field
that's that that has to be changed so
once people start reversing this then
you start seeing tumors disappearing you
start seeing blind people seeing deaf
people hearing you start seeing people
with parkinson's disease switch on i
mean you start seeing
stage four cancers reversing because now
they're you're you're you're swimming
upstream you're going to the headwaters
and making that change bond university
uh a university in australia on the gold
coast
senior researcher took the large
majority of my brain scans
and they hadn't she had them analyzed by
her graduate students and they
statistically looked at everything
one of the most startling things for the
research team
was our community's ability
to go to
to get to that point where they're
nobody no one no thing no where no time
and i'm talking four seconds
i'm talking five seconds i'm talking
nine seconds just like just give me a
second i know how to do this they
they've practiced it enough times that
the creative moment is when you get
beyond yourself when you dissociate from
everything known in your material world
turns out when you do that and you start
changing your brain waves
your brain waves slow down into alpha
and theta
you're suppressing the memory bank of
the known self that keeps you plugged
into three-dimensional reality when you
quiet down this mechanism
now
all of a sudden you start connecting to
that field and when you can stay
conscious in those subconscious realms
when you can literally regulate and
change brain waves now you're in the
operating system where you can make
those significant changes i always say
to people
when was the last time you sat with your
heart and just worked with it like so
that it's not contracted and afraid and
protected
it takes practice to to do that and and
so we we work with people in letting
them
we give them numerous opportunities
to practice this over and over and over
again and sooner or later pedal by pedal
it starts to bloom and all of a sudden
there's an authentic smile on their face
and once energy meets the heart
it goes right to the brain we have
we did this study where we hooked up an
electrocardiogram to an
electroencephalogram an
electroencephalogram is a brain mapping
machine so we measure 19 or 26 different
compartments and we're looking to see
all different kind of activity in the
brain
but we measure the heart along with it
and when the heart starts beating
coherently
in a sense of order like like taking a
big sheet j and going like that
the heart sends a wave right up to the
brain
and the brain goes into these beautiful
states of alpha the heart is telling the
brain it's safe to create again it's
safe to imagine it's safe to dream of a
new future
and
there's the stroke volume of the heart
in order and then you see these two or
three seconds of beautiful coherent
alpha the brain is in it's it's in that
creative state then there's a pause and
it happens again and
it's it's it's beauty it's a it's a
symphony
if you don't have that mechanism you can
have all the intention in the world
but there's no carrier wave i mean
and people when they make energy reach
their heart there's an external field
that's created it's it's it's magnetic
it's it's it's measurable
and that energy
is frequency and if that frequency is
coherent it can carry the intent
or thought on a coherent brain of that
future the energy of suffering
cannot carry the thought of health or
wealth it's not consistent with it it
carries a different set of thoughts
so then
the training then
is getting people into those hard states
because
once they start trading that fear or
that pain or that frustration or trying
or whatever forcing you know control
for gratitude and they just let all that
go and i say to them listen
if you can't feel gratitude if you can't
feel love i just want to know what
you've been practicing feeling every day
because that feeling that you're
practicing is what you're always feeling
now let's practice feeling something
else in the beginning it's not going to
be easy but you got to keep following
the formula keep doing it keep doing it
keep doing it
well
when they start feeling gratitude it's
very interesting because
the emotional signature of gratitude
is that something wonderful just
happened to you
something favorable is happening to you
right so
you've just received something or you're
receiving something you say thank you so
gratitude
is the ultimate state of receiving
emotionally
so when you move into a state of
gratitude and you open your heart you
will accept believe and surrender to the
thoughts equal to that emotional state
and you'll program your autonomic
nervous system into a different destiny
you could say i'm healthy i'm healthy
i'm healthy i'm wealthy i'm wealthy and
wealthy and wealthy i'm free i'm free
i'm free and your body is conditioned in
the misery and it's saying no you're not
and that thought stops right at the
brain stem
it never makes it to the body because
the body is on a different program
so then
while the person starts trading that and
they start opening their heart well
their immune system gets stronger by 50
50 in three days they start making
immunoglobulins their body's natural
defense against viruses and bacteria 50
not a little bit
a lot that's that's one study and so
trading that
telling the body it's in the in the
environment where it already happened
and so that's when the miracles start
happening that's when people say
i'm not doing anything well of course
you're not
you don't have to what are a few things
we can do to support our inner
environment on a daily basis ah
well listen um the first thing and the
most important thing for me is knowledge
and information
knowledge is really power and and
knowledge and information about yourself
shouldn't it should empower you it
should empower the self right so when we
learn about the immune system and all
that can do and you say oh my god you
mean not every virus
gets to me in fact no and the more you
the more you understand that and the
more you coax your immune system into
love and into
like we well i just did this little
thing on um
on our social media where i was talking
about the inner army of order and what
would be the signal you would want that
inner army to get and so we created this
meditation we said what would
invincibility feel like signal your body
and feel invincible how would you feel
if you had an uncompromising will
that you had more energy than you could
possibly imagine show your body what it
feels like
because it is that emotion
of invincibility that emotion of an
uncompromising goal to empower your
inner world and you have the intent of
that's what it's for wow get ready
because you're going to start creating a
cadence and a rhythm where your your
body's going whoa what what are the what
is all these new chemicals what are all
these new signals right hey it's time
hey hey
now all of a sudden receptor sites on
the t cells go wow we got some new
signals coming from the boss here let's
open up all those t-cell receptors let's
go we in fact we're we're we would love
a little fight right now because we got
a lot of time on our hands and we got
all our receptors turned on
oh i mean that that would be
a signal for your body we also know that
if you could just trade fear
and frustration and
resentment and
suffering
uh for an elevated emotion and truly
open your heart again and practice doing
that um
you'll heal you'll heal you'll heal
because i mean all healings happen in
the heart our immune system is kind of
like our rudimentary nervous system it
has cells that are mobile and they're
called plasma cells or white blood cells
and their job is an internal defense in
many of our bodies plasma cells
line the mucous membranes gut the
digestive tract
all the orifices of the body the nose
the mouth ears
and it's a line of defense against
foreign invaders and toxins and when the
immune system is
facing
some foreign invader whether it be a
virus
a bacteria a mold a fungus
some foreign agent
it is the army of plasma cells that move
towards the danger
uh and begin to uh attack these foreign
agents
and
there are cells in your immune system
called t cells and t cells are like the
ninjas of the immune system
they release
very powerful chemicals that can
denature and break down any foreign
invader
and t cells have these little trumpets
that stick out on the receptor site so
picture this big circular spherical glob
and you have all these different
receptors and these t-cell receptors are
these long trumpet
[Music]
appendages and when they come up to a
virus or they come up to
a bacteria when they come up to even a
cancer cell
they notice that it is a foreign agent
and immediately this t cell receptor
attaches to that foreign agent and
begins to release a lot of unhealthy
chemicals that begin to cause that
foreign agent to to die and then
memorizes
that foreign agent and passes the
information onto the army of the rest of
the white blood cells in the body and
this is a strong immune system and when
plasma cells and white blood cells
begin to function well they release
chemicals called immunoglobulins
and immunoglobulins are proteins that
are in the shape of a y
and those y shaped proteins are
antibodies and what they do is when the
the white blood cell releases an
antibody
it begins to block the receptors
of the foreign agent that's trying to
attack
the white blood cells so when a healthy
immunoglobulin is
released
it suppresses
the
the warfare uh the the cell receptors
that are trying to attack the white
blood cell and now you have a strong
defense you have a strong immune system
and yeah your body right now is doing
that in fact your body is always
evaluating all those foreign agents
whether it's a virus a bacteria or even
a cancer cell
and it's working to keep the body in
balance and the immune system a strong
healthy immune system does that
constantly always behind the scenes of
your awareness if you give people sound
information
and then they can repeat that
information
they're wiring it in their brain
they're creating a new model of
understanding
if you show them how to apply that
information
if they do it properly they will have
some type of transformation
that transformation
isn't something that causes people to
feel bad or unworthy it causes them to
open their hearts
it causes them to feel joy
to feel gratitude they feel differently
and if you're able to then
create that elevated emotion
and you teach people more information
they will continue to transform
themselves and that's called evolution
if you think the same thoughts the same
thoughts always lead to the same choices
the same choices lead to the same
behaviors the same behaviors create the
same experiences and the same
experiences produce the same feelings
and you're now caught in your old self
but
new thoughts
should lead to new choices and new
choices should lead to new behaviors new
behaviors should create new experiences
and new experiences should create new
emotions and that should inspire
evolution
we say that your personality
creates your personal reality
and your personality is made up of how
you think
how you act and how you feel we could
say that your personality
is your state of being
so now geniuses
if you keep thinking the same thoughts
keep demonstrating the same behaviors
keep living by the same feelings and
emotions your personal reality is going
to stay exactly the same
but
if you have new thoughts
that lead to new choices that
demonstrate new actions that create new
experiences that cause you to feel
differently you will begin to walk into
a new future how many people understand
this
so most people try to create a new
personal reality as the same personality
and it doesn't work
you literally have to become
someone else
so
crossing the river of change going from
the old self to the new self requires
you stepping into the unknown
and if you are now in the unknown and
you feel uncomfortable because you're
leaving guilt behind
[Music]
you leave unworthiness behind you see
the biggest problem with most people
is they want to create wealth but they
feel lack
they want a new life but they feel
unworthy
that's mind and body in opposition
and our research shows that you can
teach people how to recondition their
body to a new mind
and when that occurs
they begin to create very powerful
things in their life what do you believe
is the purpose of life overall
to figure out the purpose of life
okay i know i mean i mean i i really
think it's i think the mathematics
that i've looked at says
there's infinite experiences to have you
will never know the end
so then
if you study any religion i i mean i've
looked at a lot of them it's this
concept of eternity that the soul is
going to be around for eternity
that's a long time
and that means you got to be okay with
you
for a very long time yeah so
i think it's i think it's the creation
of more experiences and i think
to to
i think we came from source from
singularity from oneness
yeah and we have descended down into
density a fooled by our senses into
separation
and every
single being has a spark of oneness of
the divine within them and we got so
separate
that we now have our own free will to
answer the question is there more
because if your oneness it gets kind of
boring after a while like is there
anything else well the moment you ask if
there's anything else you're no longer
oneness you're something other than
oneness right and you're
a a different consciousness separate
from oneness
so i think then we live life and then
when we can predict the feeling of
everything that can happen in our life
and gets boring and
we're not impressed by anyone or
anything we ask the same question
is there more and that's when the soul
goes
all right well it's been how many
lifetimes you've been doing this okay
there's an awakening and the and we ask
that question and then all of a sudden
we start getting information and books
and stuff and meet people and it gets
exciting and and it's the it's it's how
the universe works and so we climb out
of this
and i just think there's so many
incredible experiences that are left in
the unknown uh that we get to have and
and then of course when
the journey's over and you've evolved to
that point
then you take that wisdom and you say
here's what i learned and it was scary
down there and i was like boy i tell a
great story and then you hang out there
and you go
is there anything else besides and here
we go again it just never
that's my theory so how do we brainwash
ourselves
in times of stress and anxiety
in order to become more peaceful loving
and successful
in the future how do we brainwash
ourselves in a different way
sure well um
that's what uh i have spent just about
my whole life
and and um
wow i mean
the first and most important thing is
that you have to understand
that if 95 of who you are is a set of
unconscious programs
then the first step is lighting a match
in a dark place if you want to become
someone else you got to become aware of
who you are
yes that means you got to start thinking
about what you've been thinking about
you got to start paying attention to how
you speak got to be conscious you
demystify the word meditation and the
word meditation literally means become
familiar with yeah when you become so
familiar with your thoughts so aware of
your emotions so conscious of your
habits that you wouldn't go unconscious
to them again now you're no longer the
program right so so getting people
disentangled from that program we found
out as a formula and when we teach
people how to do certain things with
their focus
and opening their awareness when we
teach them how to create a very
disorderly brain that has been driven by
the hormones of stress into a more
orderly coherent brain and teach them
how to open their focus and practice
that they'll come up against those
thoughts and they'll become so familiar
with them listen to this they won't
believe him anymore when they come up
any longer wow and so when they hear him
in their day they'll be like that's not
going to stop me from my future
so if they're sitting there and they
want to quit
just because they're sitting still
and they're not quitting
then they're developing a will that's
greater than those programs and you're
breaking out of the shell and you keep
doing that you're going to get up and do
the work every day because you did it
yesterday and you're going to want to do
more of that because you're getting out
of your past and it feels better and if
you keep doing that and you keep feeling
better every day the question is why
wouldn't you do it every day because you
would ultimately just feel better and
then the more whole you feel means the
more you are connected to your future
imagine if you felt every single day
and this is what i do work on
if i could stay connected to the
emotions of my future all day long
there's no way i would be looking for
when it would be happening how could i
look for when it would be happening if i
feel like it's happening i wouldn't look
anymore which means i wouldn't be
separate from it and that's when you
start creating the magic right that's
when you're in that zone and that's when
that reaffirms that personality that
you're becoming and now you don't you
know wake up in the morning oh god i
gotta create my future now you're you're
you're gonna jump out of bed be excited
you're not gonna want that magic to end
your brain is organized to reflect
everything you know in your life
your brain
is a record of the past
it's an artifact
of all the things you've learned and
experienced to this moment
so if you wake up every morning
and get out of bed on the same side
shut the alarm clock off with the same
finger
shuffle into the bathroom and use the
toilet like you always do
go and get a cup of coffee and drink
coffee out of your favorite mug
then get in the shower and wash yourself
off in the same routine way
drive to work
get to work see the same people
that push the same emotional buttons
do the same things that you've memorized
and do so well
then hurry up and go home
and hurry up and check your emails
and hurry up and check your facebook and
then watch your favorite television show
then hurry up and go to bed
here's my question
did your brain change at all that day
we could say that you were thinking the
same thoughts performing the same
unconscious actions
living by the same emotions but secretly
expecting your life to change
so there's a principle in neuroscience
and the principle says
nerve cells that fire together
wire together
so if you're thinking the same thoughts
making the same choices
demonstrating the same behaviors
reproducing the same experiences that
stamp the same networks of neurons into
the same patterns
and then produce the same emotions
you're going to hardwire your brain
into a very finite signature
because as you fire and wire the same
circuits in the same way
those circuits begin to become more
connected
and by the time you're 35 years old this
is science now
we become a set of memorized behaviors
unconscious habits
automatic emotional reactions beliefs
and perceptions and even attitudes that
function
just like a computer program
and if you do something over and over
and over again
the repetition of those actions over
time conditions your body to know how to
do it well better than your mind
and a habit is when your body knows
better than your mind
where you've done something so many
times that the body now knows how to do
it better than the brain
and so 95 percent of most people's
behaviors
attitudes thoughts beliefs
emotional reactions are subconscious
programs
so why is that important
because you're here this week
to learn new information
and every time you learn something new
you make new connections in your brain
that's what learning is
learning is forging new synaptic
connections
physical evidence
as a result of your interaction in the
environment
and the footprints of consciousness is
called learning making new connections
and the nobel prize laureate kandel in
the year 2000
found that when people learned one bit
of information
they doubled the number of connections
in their brain from 1300 connections to
2600 connections
but if they didn't review that
information if they couldn't repeat it
if they couldn't remember it those
circuits pruned apart in hours or days
so if learning is making new synaptic
connections
then remembering is maintaining and
sustaining those connections your body
rejects viruses all the time of course
it has memorized certain viruses that
you've been exposed to
it's memorized certain bacteria that
you've been exposed to and it's beaten
those viruses not every virus wins in
the body the body has an intelligence
and it's and it has
quite a library of memories in the in
the in the white blood cells so your
body is fighting viruses and bacteria
all the time there's a constant
competition going on really so our
research shows that four days
of opening your heart
releases immunoglobulin a your body's
primary defense against bacteria and
viruses it's better than the flu shot
it's the body's natural flu shot and
that's the innate intelligence of the
body saying i got this i got a lot of
energy in fact i got a surplus of energy
in fact i'm radiating energy and now too
much about the world people well now my
outer world is not controlling my inner
world my inner world now is functioning
independent of what's going on in my
outer world and now
you're manifesting your manifesto ah now
you got it now you're in a creative
state because people are coming to you
yes right exactly now you're a magnet
now you have a field right and you have
energy
to heal and our research shows that that
field around your body will actually
expand you you radiate more light and
information cells
are getting new information that that
are causing
light to be exchanged between cells and
information now the body's getting an
upgrade so so that immunoglobulin a in
four days went up 50 percent
so now we now know that if it's going up
50 that then the immune system was
getting a new signal and nitric oxide
then
causes another chemical to activate the
arteries in your heart to swell and now
just like when energy moves into your
sexual organs and it swells with blood
and you have energy there the same
intensity it moves into your heart
and now
now the heart is activated and what do
you feel
you feel an incredible amount of love
yeah and love you
you feel you feel whole and now the more
whole you feel our research shows
then the less separate you feel from the
things you want in your life because you
feel like you already have them you only
want things when you're in lack but when
you feel whole then it feels like it's
already happened and that tends to be
the exact emotion
that causes those synchronicities and
serendipities and coincidences to happen
in our life and you say to a person what
are you doing and they're saying i'm not
doing anything i'm i'm just i'm loving
life i'm being myself i'm yeah right i'm
free i'm free from the past i'm free
from my story of the past in fact i'm
more connected to the energy of my
future than i am to the energy of my
past
i'm believing in my future more than i'm
believing in my past when we become the
living example of truth when we actually
embody this uh
that
there are no limits to what we can do
and i'm hopeful with human beings that
that we have this capacity and
and of course when we believe in
ourselves we believe in possibility and
when we believe in possibilities we
believe in ourselves and i think that is
the ultimate belief let's demystify
meditation because it has so many
stigmas around it close your eyes
retreat from your life
disconnect from your body disconnect
from your environment disconnect from
your schedule
and just give yourself an hour or 45
minutes or 20 minutes because when you
invest in yourself you invest in your
future and when you believe in yourself
you believe in possibilities and when
you believe in possibilities you believe
in yourself and if you don't believe in
possibilities then you don't believe in
yourself and you don't believe in
yourself you don't believe in
possibilities so then but if you have a
community a living organism yeah where
it's becoming the new normal yes and you
want to join that living organism and
you want to you want to be a part of
that and and every every stride you make
feeds the living organism every stride
every effort you make
to connect is is amazing because that
which we are seeking is seeking us
it's not like
it is it matches our efforts
and so then when when people have that
uncompromising will
the same way that they go shopping for a
dress or a pair of earrings or go to the
gym and work out with the same intensity
with the same passion
come up against themselves and just say
when the body's going given everything
it has it's when you say that's all you
got that's it that's all you're going to
put out to
i'm ready yeah and so then
when you start overcoming that
the side effect of it is that all of a
sudden you're happy for no reason
and you're less seduced in believing
that something else you need something
outside of it outside of you to make you
feel better all of a sudden you're
feeling better every day without
anything outside of you
and now all of a sudden you start
showing up unpredictable in your life
they're saying that ed guy he's
different he's on a different medication
but in actuality you're just freer right
and so so then as we begin to remove
these layers that stop the flow of the
divine in us that had an essence in us
the side effect is we become more
willful we become more mindful we become
more conscious we become more loving
it's it's it's nature you know it's just
it just it comes becomes who we are at
the end of the day if you really wanted
to be wealthy say
how did i do today did i make the right
choices what was i ethical was i purpose
driven was i was i was am i interested
in making a difference was i fair was i
tempered
did i really think before i spoke what
did i remember reading about that book
about that person that did it how did i
do
and if you said when did i fall from
grace when did i lose it
okay
i want that opportunity again
i want another shot at that and i'm
going in this way what would love do in
this situation what would greatness do
and now you you evolve your experience
and somehow there's a door there's an
opening something shifts something's
changing and now here we go we climb
another ladder and then all of a sudden
there's another challenge and then
people who finally arrive at their
abundance they could care less if
they're abundant they're already knowing
that they've earned the right for it so
so there's sometimes a shortcut in the
process
if we're if we really learn and we
really get it but the trial and error is
so
important because
not only is the person earning the right
to be wealthy
but they're earning the right to live in
worthiness worthy to receive like hey
you people people come to our work all
the time for a lot of reasons and one of
the common reasons is they want to get
healthy yeah and in their own because
they're dealing with a very serious
health condition and i always say the
same thing to him
stop wanting to be healthy learn the
formula yeah on how to get healthy learn
the formula on how to heal and the
healing will be the side effect of it if
you're obsessing about why am i not
healed you're still the old person
you can become that person every day
right
turns out that when you sit down
and the people that we interview that
have had significant changes
when it's no longer about their health
but they are
they are out of the bleachers and
they're on the playing field and they
are coming up against the belief like
one lady said god i i always thought
that
this work really worked this kind these
concepts are the truth but i never
believed it worked for me and i was in a
car accident in a wheelchair and then
she made the decision that she was going
to overcome that belief now it was no
longer about her healing it was about
overcoming the belief but she overcame
the belief and showed up every day for
herself when you believe in yourself you
believe in possibilities when you
believe in possibilities you got to
believe in yourself you don't show up
for yourself
you don't believe in it yeah and that's
why people don't do the work i mean if
you you believe that your thoughts
created reality
you would show up every day and create
and so a lot of people believe in their
past more than they believe in their
future a lot of people fall in love or
more in love with their past or romance
their past instead of romance their
future or love their future it's it's
that simple so
the initiation process of life is always
going to be there you're always going to
be challenged if if you want to be a
master well then you better learn how to
heal someone else and you're going to
fail a lot of times and if you think
that you're a failure then you'll quit
but if you feel like you just didn't
quite ding it yet and you show up again
to just ding it and you keep evolving
your experience and go deeper how much
more can i open my heart how much more
can i surrender into this infinite field
how much more can i become can i walk is
it with my eyes open people
do meditations and they have great
meditations me included
and then you get up you open your eyes
and you're back in the program and
people want to know why they haven't
healed them we have testimonies of
people they're speaking the truth they
said my ms
my rheumatoid and my lupus never went
away
i had great meditations i felt better
and then i realized with my eyes open i
was still that person
and now
next level they're in the game catching
themselves or catching how they speak or
watching how they think they're not
letting their body fall in the same
emotional state to put them in the same
past experience that the body's
believing it now this is the this is the
great part and when a person finally
breaks through from the chains
and there's a different consciousness of
freedom that happens
they look back at their past they want
to change one thing and their past
because it brought them to that present
moment that's the path no longer
existing that's the freedom so is it
worth the effort yeah it's no longer
about healing it's no longer about
abundance it's about who you're becoming
i think that if we share
the same experiences because we like the
same things
we share the same emotions
and if we share the same experiences we
share the same emotions i can relate to
you so we can exchange ideas and
information
and if we share the same energy energy
is information so many people as an
example
they use each other to reaffirm their
their dependency on suffering so i
suffer more than you then you say i you
i suffer you suffer more than me we have
this thing we just complain with each
other well that's the same resonance the
same frequency and there's a match right
uh because the same means if you if
you're if you're
someone who's has a uh accountability
partner that that you exchange ideas
like this with and it's a different
frequency and different energy so
when energy comes together it's
constructive something comes out of it
yeah you feel it right it's and you feel
an elevation if there's dissonance then
your your sensing meter is how you feel
about that person many times in your gut
or in your heart or wherever and there's
deconstruct there's a
destructive interference and there's no
energy involved so
i think that's just a practice but
really
the ultimate mastery
is to be able to be in such residence
such coherence
that when you walk in the room that you
raise
everybody's energy and you don't let
your energy drop because of any
circumstance or any condition and that
would be greater than your environment
right and that's that's the model
that we use so imagine 1500 people
in an event
where everybody's getting super coherent
and the interference that's going on in
the room is creating these high
amplitudes now we've measured that in
the room and the energy in the room is
off the chart many times there's i mean
there's energy for healing in there
there's energy for all kinds of things
that can happen so we brought it to life
with our awareness and so
the more elevated the emotion love
gratitude freedom bliss ecstasy the
higher the frequency
so but it turns out you can have a
collective group of people with a lot of
energy and be incoherent and it creates
entropy yeah you could have a smaller
group of people that are highly coherent
and put out a very big signal
so when we see a collective really get
coherent
wow the energy in the room opens up
doors
of possibilities that i would i would
never expect i mean i i don't i don't
know how to explain some of the
phenomenological things that happen
but that's that's everybody's divine
like everybody's everybody's in that
state they're they're in that elevated
state so
i think our i think our truth meter
is really whether we feel it lifted
uh or we feel like we've been robbed if
you are not
defined by some vision
that is bigger than you
and you are not passionate about that
vision then you're left with the old
hardware of the past in your brain and
you will be predictable in your life
so would you agree then
new thoughts
new information should lead to new
choices
new choices should lead to new behaviors
and new behaviors should create new
experiences
and new experiences should produce new
emotions
and those new emotions should drive new
thoughts and that's called evolution
so if your brain is a record of the past
and you don't have a vision of the
future
then you are living in the past
and you will never arrive at that new
future feelings and emotions are the end
product of past experiences
and you can remember experiences better
because you can remember how they feel
and when you're in the midst of an
experience
all of your senses plug you into the
environment
and as you're gathering all this vital
data from your external world
all that information rushes back to your
brain
and it causes jungles of neurons to
organize themselves into networks
the moment those neurons string into
place the brain makes a chemical and
that chemical is called a feeling or an
emotion
and once you feel that emotion you
create a long-term memory
now reason this with me
if feelings and emotions are the end
product of past experiences
and you are feeling the same way
every single day
doesn't that mean nothing new is
happening in your life
and if those feelings and emotions drive
certain thoughts
and you can't think greater than how you
feel
because you had events in your life that
have branded you emotionally
and you feel sadness or guilt or shame
or unworthiness or insecurity
all of those emotions are created from
past experiences
and when you feel those emotions
and those emotions drive certain
thoughts
and then those thoughts make certain
chemicals for you to feel the same
emotion and then those emotions drive
certain thoughts
the repetition of that cycle then
conditions the body
to memorize that emotional state better
than the mind
and now your body literally is in the
past
because if you can't think greater than
how you feel then you are thinking in
the past
and so most people then
spend the majority of their life
talking about
why they never arrive at their vision of
the future
because of some past experience
and so if feelings and emotions are the
end product of past experiences you
remember your first kiss
you remember your wedding you remember
the birth of your children you remember
catching a fish off the coast of
manzanillo with your three best friends
because you caught the fish and it was a
new experience and you felt great
and then you went
to the casita and you cooked the
mahi-mahi and you drank sauvignon blanc
and the wind was blowing off the sea and
the sun was setting
and you made a long-term memory
[Music]
but you also have memories that are
connected to trauma and crisis
to disappointments
and those are the memories that people
remember more than anything else
and so if you haven't overcome some
emotion
that keeps you anchored to the past
then you tell a story about the past
and people say
i am this way because of this experience
that happened to me
15 years ago
i am this way because of some event that
happened 30 years ago
and from a biological perspective
it means i haven't been able to change
in the last fifteen or thirty years
and scientific american
a prestigious magazine
says that fifty percent
of what you talk about in your past
isn't even the truth
you make it up
because you don't have the same brain
that you did 15 years ago or 30 years
ago
so then your brain and body are
typically in the past
because thoughts
are the language of the brain
and feelings are the language of the
body and how you think and how you feel
creates your state of being
so if you think insecure thoughts
in a matter of seconds you are going to
feel insecure
the moment you feel insecure
your brain is monitoring how you're
feeling and you think more insecure
thoughts
which then makes you feel more insecure
and the repetition of that cycle
conditions the body to become the mind
of insecurity
and then the person says
i
am insecure
and whenever you say i am anything you
are commanding your mind and body into a
destiny
so then how do people change
they wait for crisis
trauma
disease
diagnosis loss
something has to go wrong in their life
where they feel so uncomfortable that
they finally make up their mind to
change
and why is that
because after the trauma or the crisis
they don't feel like of themselves
and the moment they don't feel like
themselves they could actually observe
themselves
because they are looking at themselves
through the eyes of someone else
but my message is why wait
you can learn and change in a state of
pain and suffering
or you can learn and change in a state
of joy and inspiration memory is
creative that in fact fifty percent of
that story you embellish
people make up that story let me tell
you why they make up that story
because they excuse themselves for the
fact that they haven't been able to
change
since that event they'll have to make it
sound worse than it really was to make
it harder to grow and change
so that they can reaffirm their limited
sense of their inability to change so
then that story becomes more and more of
a story it's less of the truth because
you got to work yourself up into a state
there were lions and tigers and there
were right you know they were helicopter
snowstorms and everybody was firing
bullets
worse than you could possibly imagine
and then you got to feel that emotion
right and then you look at this oh yeah
it must have been really bad now that's
that's your identity now that's your
identity well here's the deal with
trauma and it's kind of an interesting
thing because when you're traumatized
some threat or some danger or some
condition in your outer world
through your senses is changing how you
feel in your inner world
and the quotient of change between the
way you normally feel
in some alarm state when you change your
internal state and move into that
emergency mode you narrow your focus
on the cause and the brain
freezes an image and takes a snapshot
and that's called the long-term memory
and now that image is branded
holographically into the brain
so then
they remember experience our experience
is better because we can remember how
they feel and and that memory then
changes the person's biology
so they think neurologically within the
circuits of that experience and they
feel chemically within the boundaries of
those emotions and how we think and feel
becomes our state of being
so now the person
biologically has changed and many times
it's the strong emotion that begins to
select and instruct the gene that
creates disease why
because
if the environment signals the gene and
that's the truth that's epigenetics and
the end product of an experience and the
environment is an emotion
the emotion that you feel from that
event is literally selecting the gene
for you to begin to change and genes
make proteins and so the the person if
it's if it's strong enough begins to
wear their trauma not just in their
brain
now it's in their body because every
time they think about that trauma every
time they review it every time
they keep creating the imagery they keep
firing and wiring the circuits in their
brain
and they keep feeling the feeling
emotionally in their body and their body
is so objective
that it's believing it's living in the
same past experience 50 to 100 times a
day and all you need is a stimulus and
response an image and an emotion a
thought and a feeling and you're
conditioning the body into the past well
you're conditioning the brain body into
the past why is our memory
for
pain stronger than our memory of a
success or a joy i really think that
when the survival gene is activated
preservation is the key so we can have
10 things
that happen really great in our lives
you have a family member or somebody you
know that does this they have 10 really
great things happen in their one thing
bad and they focus on that bad thing why
because the survival genes activated
they want to make sure it doesn't happen
again so so you put your attention on it
because
you don't want it to happen again so
what people do when they're aroused is
they start thinking it's gonna happen so
they actually select the worst
case scenario in their mind
and then emotionally embrace that future
before it happens
and they're conditioning their body
to become the mind of anxiety and fear
so in preservation and in survival if
you prepare for the worst
anything less that happens you have a
better chance of surviving so that's the
mechanism that takes place so
survival means you better take care of
your body yeah you better be aware of
your environment and make sure there's
no threats and so you got to keep your
eye out there
and you better be thinking about the
future based on what you learned in the
past now there's nothing wrong with that
when the analytical facilities are in
balance but when there's an arousal
arousal there's three things that create
arousal fear
hostility and anger or aggression and
pain
and that arousal drives the brain
into these high states of what we call
high beta
and most people need something or
someone or some circumstance or some
drug or some pill or some computer game
to change that internal state and the
moment they notice a change in their
internal state then they pay attention
to what's causing it they start
developing a dependency on it right
so
it turns out that when we teach people
how to self-regulate and change their
brain waves
uh we could actually see then that the
incoherence the disorderliness that's
taking place in the brain you know when
you're over aroused you're overly
analytical and you're shifting your
attention from one problem to one person
to one thing to one place to another
problem to another circumstance to your
phone to your car and each one of those
elements has a neurological network in
the brain so the arousal causes these
different circuits to fire out of order
and the brain is incoherent so take two
waves that are out of phase and mix them
when they interfere they flatten out
there's no energy so energy leaves the
brain right
so then
when you're in arousal you narrow your
focus on the cause if there's something
rattling in the bushes and it's dark you
freeze and you narrow your focus on it
and there's a rush of adrenaline and
your pupils dilate and your heart starts
to race and you're ready to run fight or
hide i mean that's a survival moment but
what if it's your co-worker
sitting right next to you or six feet
away and and you're judging them you're
the same arousal's taking place and
what's once very adaptive becomes very
maladaptive this is where it gets
challenging so when we teach people how
to open their focus we've done
thousands and thousands of brain scans
and they get beyond their analytical
processes and they open their awareness
and go from a conversion focus to a
divergent focus and they learn how to
relax and regulate their brain waves
start to slow down into alpha and then
if they do it properly and they're
connecting
those different compartments of the
brain that were once firing out of order
start to unify different communities
form bigger communities the brain starts
to synchronize and then all of a sudden
you start seeing different compartments
of the brain all in resonance so now
when they're all in resonance and they
start interfering when those waves come
together there's more energy in the
brain
so when a person dials down the
mechanism this neocortex that plugs us
into three-dimensional reality that
keeps us aware of our body that's the
autobiographical self where everything's
stitched in memory in there
when we start deactivating the mechanism
here and we get beyond the memory bank
of the known self and brainwaves move
into theta we've
we've studied this so much
when a person can let their body
be in a light state of sleep and feel so
safe
that you can finally let go and
surrender the body is
sleeping but the mind is awake and now
the door between the conscious mind and
the subconscious mind is wide open and
if they can regulate and stay there
something amazing happens
there is a release of energy
from the body and their brain goes into
a very very super coherent state of
gamma and gamma is super consciousness
now i'm not talking about a little gamma
i'm not talking about a lot of gamma i'm
not talking about a really loud gamma
i'm talking about a supernatural amount
of gamma
there's so much order
and so much energy in the brain like if
we were in an audience and we were all
clapping like this
that could be alpha right theta would be
and if everybody could do this the
slower we could do it the more we can
get our timing down the more we can get
coherent but if we were doing
this it would be really hard for all of
us to do that at the same time it takes
a lot of order a lot of awareness a lot
of energy to be able to create that kind
of
order so
that's how fast the brain is and that
arousal
that's taking place is ecstasy
that arousal is bliss it is the most
familiar
unfamiliar feeling that people ever have
in
that memory then
that the person has that is so
profoundly different
than the feeling of success
the feeling of wealth the feeling of
orgasm or love or whatever this is a new
one and it's a thrill
and the person notices a dramatic change
in their inner state
and with that experience comes a very
lucid picture a very profound insight a
download of
information that's the moment then
the body many times rewrites the
biological program energy
is in forming matter and the autonomic
nervous system is regulating it's in
high order and remember disease is
autonomic dysregulation
now it's getting into a very very high
frequency of order and it's sending very
coherent information to the cells and
tissues sending energy to the cells and
tissues and cells begin to emit more
coherent light and information
and then there's the disease
and there it's not you asked if is it
possible then can that people can heal
that quickly in one week yeah because
what if they create an inner event
that carries an amplitude of gratitude
or joy or freedom breakthrough from the
chains of the past when the body is
liberated and you feel that elevated
emotion
the stronger the emotion you feel from
that breakthrough the more you're going
to pay attention to the image in your
mind and now you're now beginning to
brand new circuitry in the brain and
your body's being conditioned into a new
future and the stronger the emotion you
feel the more you pay attention to the
picture the more you're conditioning the
body over time to the future instead of
the past so now
you keep knocking on that genetic door
emotionally
then that emotion ultimately signals a
new gene
that
up regulates that gene to produce better
proteins and the person then all of a
sudden starts healing and we have
research to show
that people can do that in four days
signal genes to reduce cancer cells and
wow
just to signal stem cells to to suppress
um
uh to go to active tissues and repair
them and regenerate them and suppress
inflammation you come with a lot of
genes and they're just a library of
potentials they're just a storehouse of
information of possibilities so then you
got to get the right signal the right
lock into the key that begins to select
and instruct genes that cause genes to
make different proteins and you can
regulate so many different genes the
same genes you can regulate them
differently so when they up regulate
they start producing really healthy and
robust proteins and that's that's
enzymes that's tissue that structure
that's function that's hormones
it's immune immunoglobulins when they
down regulate because of some alarm when
there's not a lot of energy
for long-term building projects well
then you keep doing that then the body
starts producing cheaper proteins it's a
different signal it's not a time for
growth when you hit pay dirt like that
when you connect when you connect to the
field when you connect the divine
whatever you want to call it when your
consciousness merges with a greater
consciousness and that arousal creates
ecstasy bliss oneness whatever you want
to call that
you realize that it never came from
anything out there it didn't come from
the wardrobe or the facelift the sports
car whatever
it came from within you and so you stop
looking out there for it and now the
love affair begins and you never want to
miss a date because it's just too good
so that memory then
that is what i'm after
because when you have those
transcendental moments and you
understand this yeah
the experience of that transcendental
moment
lays down new circuitry in the brain
that's what experience does
and the experience produces a feeling
but it's not chemical
it's electric and it's orderly and every
cell of your body is
jiggling in an order and there and
you're aroused and you're awakened right
you have to admit when that occurs
your spectrum of reality is going to
broaden some conditioning some illusion
something is removed and you start
seeing reality as it is and all of a
sudden you start seeing the part that we
edit out for survival now you start
seeing patterns and lights and
information
that are transcendent of
three-dimensional reality and your
spectrum why because your brain had the
experience and the circuitry is there
and now your your experience of the
world changes you get an upgrade to the
to the vr set the virtual reality said
oh you had the upgrade 2.0 and now it
looks different everything looks
different everybody looks different
the world look you're seeing beauty more
well and there's more holism and more
connection and sounds and words and
music and sense and sight and light is
all working together
i mean that's the blessing of an
awakening right that's where that's
where we're going what do you think the
world humanities challenge will be over
the next decade as we enter 2020 um back
to the principle lewis of just different
paradigms beginning
to collapse
you know economically politically
socially environmentally religiously
education journalism the uh you know
medicine
um
they they have to
uh move into chaos and chaos is just
unpredictable not working yeah exactly
but now here's the challenge for
humanity
you have one of two ways to embrace the
breakdown of those
those paradigms
you can face them with anger and
hostility and fear and you are only
contributing to more of it
uh we have to see that those breakdowns
are essential for something greater to
happen
now
we can't wait
for governments to take care of us
that's we can't wait for
uh medicine to to give us a drug that's
going to heal us from a condition
the truth is with a greater level of
consciousness
the change in awareness because of
information
the greatest challenge we have as those
as those paradigms break down is to no
longer emotionally react in the same way
and be victims
you can't say this president this person
this this whatever is actually making me
feel this way and think this way
basically you're in the program that
you're something outside of you is
controlling you
how you feel and how you think
so then to self-regulate then is to say
how i think and feel was going to change
my outer environment so then
we're all faced with great opportunities
brilliantly disguised as impossible
situations and we are at that point at
that nexus point in our evolution as a
species so then you don't try to fix
that that's never going to work what you
do is you create something better
and then everybody just naturally just
leaves that
and goes here now it used to be some
people would just come here and the
majority would stay here because they're
clinging to
what they've been programmed or
believing but now
because of information everybody's like
that's not going to work i already know
it's not going to work and i don't care
what anybody says this is working for me
so
people are moving to new to new um
to new applications to new paradigms
because it's working for them so as long
as we don't emotionally react to the
breakdown that's happening
currently in the world and chaos is just
unpredictable order you know as as as
things move towards disorder the novelty
that's being created is literally chaos
because
the known
and everything staying the same
is order
but as you step out into that unknown
it's then you're having the chaos is
unpredictable order being expressed
through novelty and we have to be able
to learn how to take that
disorder and with the application of
brain and heart coherence create more
order so you can't just say hey i'm
standing up for peace and you know and
being being miserable with your
co-worker you you don't get to talk
about peace
until there's you you're the you're the
living prayer of peace not just we know
we know
crime rates go down and
violence goes down when there's peace
projects in communities where there's
meditation on peace but when those
peace-gathering projects end you know
you see that crime and violence and
everything returns back to the same
level so it's not enough to just think
it
we got to demonstrate it so if i'm
demonstrating peace
and you're demonstrating peace somebody
else because of mere neurons is going to
go wow that person's unpredictable wow
they're different it's given me
permission to do the same
so i think that ultimately moving into
that state of being you know as human
beings and and
and creating unity
that you know you keep watching so many
programs on television that talk you
into prejudice that talk you into
separation that talked you into fear
that talk you into violence that talk
you into war deceit
negativity
um you're you're not going to trust
anybody in fact you're going to see
difference between you and me or anybody
because that's what separation does but
when you're heart centered and you feel
connected you don't see the person any
longer right you see something
transcendent you see an essence right
and i think if you do that really well
that kind of emergence of a of a new
consciousness
uh that's less dependent
on on all of those outer things is
really difficult to control and you want
to control a community control their
emotions
and control them in survival when you
overcome your emotions you can see the
hidden meaning behind all things and
when everybody's looking this way you
may be looking that way because you
understand look you've just overcome
your fear you've just overcome your
hostility and anger you've overcome the
program of whatever it is
i swear to you you are going to be able
to connect people and that
that then
is the hope of the future that's why
that's why i'm hopeful of the future
it's so important then that of the
infinite places you can put your
attention
let's put it on your heart
now where you place your attention is
where you place your energy why because
we want this center to bloom
1400 1300 different chemicals that
restore me generate the body let's
breathe let's open this up let's
practice this let's start learn how to
lead with a heart a different
consciousness yeah in the beginning
it's a little difficult but
you stay with it and you practice it
pedal by pedal by pedal placing your
attention there you're putting your own
life force back into your heart you're
turning your love inward and the body
will start responding and in a week's
time if we're doing that three times a
day or over and over again
sooner or later that thing's gonna start
blooming and just like when your sexual
organs are aroused and they're engorged
with blood
this center
when you start feeling love you make a
chemical called oxytocin
oxytocin signals nitric oxide nitric
oxide
signals a chemical called derived
endothelial relaxing factor you know
what that is
it causes the arteries in your heart to
literally open up
so your heart is going to be filled with
blood and oxygen and nutrients it's
physiological it's going to feel full
you're going to have a heart on in a
sense your heart is going to fail right
and when that happens
you experience a level of love
that passes all understanding you your
cup runneth over i mean it is
and people are in they're sobbing
because they realize that this this
center finally like a child i think
we're all faced with great opportunities
brilliantly disguised as impossible
situations
and in order like for me personally and
i and after looking through your book
and reading a good portion of it i mean
for me there's there's no school
of ancient wisdom that you need to go to
to be initiated your life is your
initiation if you're paying attention so
we meet challenges in our life from a
certain level of mind right a certain
level of consciousness or
unconsciousness and even einstein said
we have to go to a greater level of
consciousness
than the consciousness that's created
the problem what is consciousness
consciousness is awareness and awareness
means possibilities that you haven't
thought of before
so
we confront problems or challenges in
our life and as a side note
i was having breakfast with a researcher
just last week who's studying what
happens when we perceive a condition in
our environment as a problem how it
weakens the organism they're measuring
this and when a person sees it as a
challenge how they draw energy they
raise the energy of their body back into
order
so
if we said i want to be
wealthy or i want to be healthy
well what but you want to be that
because you're not it
so the initiation of going from not it
here to it here you're going to have to
climb some steps and there's going to be
some blind spots so you try it out and
it doesn't work
well that's because there's a part of
you that's still in a habit there's part
of you that's still unconscious okay so
what is it about myself and that
circumstance
that i am feeling
about that circumstance and that feeling
is causing me to think about it so you
say oh it's impossible they'll never
change i'll hire a hitman i'll hire the
mafia i'll hire an attorney i'll have my
friend's friend to talk to him and
nothing changes right well
you're not you're not separate from that
experience you're involved in it and how
you think and how you feel broadcasts
energy into the field so your energy is
the same every day and as long as your
energy is the same nothing's going to
change in your life either and nobody
changes until they change their energy
so then
what piece of knowledge
what piece of information what would
love do what would greatness look like
okay i don't know
all right well certainly somebody in
history has faced this problem
don't get on facebook and say does
anybody have any answers don't get
go look it up and study and read and
learn you'll own it and you'll say wow
that person that was
wealthy they failed 500 times
well hell i had the wrong view of wealth
okay then failure is not a thing i got
to overcome failure well yep just
climbed a step yeah okay i'm reacting to
that circumstance with the same emotion
that emotion is firing the same thoughts
i'm broadcasting the same energy into
the field
if i were facing that circumstance and
situation again with that person that
circumstance what do i learn from that
circumstance how could i do it
differently the next time
find out a solution and rehearse it
install the circuitry so when you get in
the circumstance you're not going to
respond in an automatic habituation yeah
now you're at a greater level of
consciousness now you're looking at
possibilities that you weren't looking
at before because you were unconscious
now
that process of trial and error is so
important in the spiritual path
how many times
do we have to forget before we remember
and then we remember and we forget again
and it takes constantly remembering
until we stop forgetting and when we get
to that point now we're conscious
now there's wisdom and wisdom is the
memory
of the experience without the emotional
charge now you're ready for the new
adventure so then
people draw conclusions and say oh it's
that person that ripped me off as that
person that
what now now you don't create your
reality you only create reality when
things are good
well somehow you got to tango through
this somehow your objectivity in not
reacting emotionally
is going to change the energy of how you
address this situation consciousness is
awareness awareness is paying attention
and noticing and so 95
of who we are by the time we're 35 years
old is a set of unconscious automatic
programs that we've just practiced so
many times that we're not consciously
thinking about those so in order for you
to change to answer the initial question
that you asked
the first step is you got to become
conscious of your unconscious thoughts
and you gotta you gotta start looking at
those hard-wired thoughts that that you
think every day that are just circuits
that have been fired and wired together
how do we do that should we write a list
at the end of the day or whatever the
most common thoughts we had that day
like how does someone become aware you
don't have to do that you just have to
sit down close your eyes and not move
and then you'll get you'll you'll start
seeing what am i thinking about right
now yeah and all you want to do is
observe the thought because
when you begin to observe that thought
you're no longer the program now you're
the consciousness observing the program
and you're starting to pull out of the
program but thinking about the thinking
yeah who's doing the thinking of the
thinking
about the thinking that's who you are
when you're not the program that's
awareness right you got to become aware
of how you speak how you act become so
conscious
so aware of it that you won't go
unconscious and let that thought or that
behavior run you you got to say oh my
god
this feeling that i've been living by
for the last 20 years
is actually guilt i didn't know it was
guilt because it just feels like me
and all of a sudden as you start
becoming conscious of it you're
beginning to objectify your subjective
self you're you're pulling out of those
programs and nobody likes to do that
because it's uncomfortable they'd rather
turn on their cell phones start texting
get on the internet
you know watch tv to distract them from
that moment and that is what they have
to move through in order to get to their
to their own personal freedom so the
first step is becoming conscious and
meditation means to become familiar with
to become conscious of to to become so
conscious of your unconscious self that
you won't go unconscious to any thought
any behavior or emotion and get ready
because it takes a tremendous amount of
energy
to do that and awareness
to stay conscious and so
we fall from grace yeah fine you got it
you got you're awake you got another day
let's go again how often do you fall oh
my gosh i mean
how many times have i done it thousands
but i'm not gonna give up because
the moments in which i do connect or the
moments that i do have that
transcendental experience
what matters the most after it when i
have that transcendental moment i look
back
at all of those difficult meditations
those difficult days and those are the
ones you remember you don't remember the
good meditations you remember the ones
where you came up against yourself and
you want to look further and you said
i'm gonna go a little further and go
further or
you had a rough day and you just went in
and you just you at the end of the day
you surrender and you have the classic
oh my god moment
there's no linear correlation it's just
whether you're willing to live in
creation instead of living in survival
and so
you get better at it you know we just
get better at it and for me
staying conscious and staying aware and
staying present
is an art because
you you know when someone's present with
you in your life because they're paying
attention to you
you know when they're not present with
you because they're not paying attention
to you so imagine this field of
information this
this this intelligence that lives within
you and i that's governing everything
material in this world it's a
self-organizing intelligence
you have access to it so you better get
present with it
as well as you can get present with
anything else and just because you can't
see it
doesn't mean it doesn't exist
that that realm you can't experience
with your senses you can only experience
with your awareness
so then
people have to take their attention off
their bodies and go from a somebody to a
nobody
take their attention off the people in
their life and go from that they
identify with and go from a someone to a
no one take their attention off the
things in their life their cell phone
their computer their car and go from
something to nothing take their
attention off where they sleep where
they work where they're sitting and go
from somewhere to nowhere take their
attention off the predictable future in
the familiar past and time and go from
some time to no time and now if you're
taking all of your attention off of
everything material in this
three-dimensional reality now there's
only one other thing that's left that
means you're in awareness your
consciousness and now
that is the bridge that is the door to
the quantum field and you can't enter
the quantum field as a somebody
so
if someone has spent their whole life
working on having the perfect body or so
much so they have so much attention on
their pain
where you place your attention is where
you place your energy it's going to take
some work for them to take all of their
attention off their body right because
they'll go they'll do it and then
they'll go back let's see if the pain's
still there oh the pain's still there so
it's a little bit of a waltz in the
beginning but as people start applying
this
you start getting better at it can you
believe in a future
that you can't see or experience with
your senses yet
but you've thought about enough times in
your mind that your brain is literally
changed to look like the event has
already occurred
latest research in neuroscience
says you can change your brain from
living in the past to living in the
future
and can you fall in love with that
vision
to such a degree
that you come out of your resting state
and change guilt or suffering into
inspiration and joy and gratitude
to such a degree that your body as the
unconscious mind does not know the
difference between that external event
and what you're creating internally
so that your body believes it's living
in that future in the present moment and
you begin to signal new genes
in new ways
to change your body
to look like the event has already
occurred
the latest research in epigenetics says
you can change your body by thought
alone
now reason this with me
if there's physical evidence
in your brain and body
to look like the event has already
occurred
your brain and body are no longer living
in the past they're living in the future
and you will walk right into your vision
most people in this audience
all of you
have done something great in your life
you all have
reason
this woke up one day or you had a wild
thought out of nowhere
and that thought
was a possibility in the future
something new you wanted to experience
and the moment you started thinking
about this experience
the moment you started contemplating
this potential reality
you turned on a part of your brain
called the frontal lobe
the crowning achievement of the human
being
it's 40 percent of your entire brain
it is the creative center
and it has connections to all other
parts of the brain
and the moment you said what would it be
like to be a leader
what would it be like to be successful
what would it be like to have this
vision come true
the moment you asked that open-ended
question
you turned on this part of the brain
because the rest of the brain is just a
bunch of automatic programs
and now the frontal lobe the creative
center wakes up
and it has connections to the entire
brain it's the ceo it's the boss it's
the symphony leader of the brain
and the moment you get creative the
frontal lobe begins to select different
networks of neurons that are stored in
your brain from things you've learned or
experienced
and as you begin to think a what-if
question
it begins to select these different
networks and begins to seamlessly piece
them together
and making your brain fire in new
sequences and in new patterns and new
combinations
and whenever you make your brain work
differently you're changing your mind
because mind is the brain in action
mind is the brain at work
and the moment those neurons fire in
tandem
you get a picture in your mind
a hologram
a vision
an abstraction
and for those people who are passionate
that thought that their thinking begins
to create an elevated emotion
they become inspired
they feel enthusiastic in theos filled
with god
they become passionate
they started to open their hearts
and all of a sudden they're combining a
clear intention with an elevated emotion
and it's the combination of a clear
intention and an elevated emotion in our
research over and over again
that proves then the person now is
changing fundamentally changing
biologically
changing internally
and their brain and body are moving from
living in the past into living in the
future we have such compelling evidence
in science with brain scans you make
your brain work better you can make your
heart work better you make your immune
system work better you can make your
cells go from really sick to really
healthy we've got great evidence you can
become immune to serious viruses you can
be immune to bacteria we've got the
measurements you can blame in your life
we have great evidence and the people
aren't monks they're not they're not
nuns they're not religious scholars
they're just common people
and then we have testimony
of people who are the example of truth
they are they are the example of truth i
would rather have dinner with those
people than anybody anybody out there
they know something right
so evidence then becomes the loudest
voice right and and that's why i think
what people are looking for right now
the truth is so lost in sensationalism
and the truth is so lost
in emotional agreement
and so people who want to feel fear
they program themselves and accept
believe and surrender that people who
want to be hate be hateful
it's all there it's all there and it's a
it's a matrix to find the way out right
and
and i think i think there's a door i
just i just think that we have to
trust the innate information that that
comes from within us the recognition
that
when you're assimilating a negative
thought or a negative judgment
or a negative emotion envy
greed whatever it may be
that's actually lowering your energy
yeah and when you get to that place
where you're experiencing that
incredible bliss right here you can you
can't yeah and even if you have the
thought and the thought will still come
because we still have those stories but
the thought
will be an understanding of human nature
because you're no longer
at that vibrational level anymore you're
rising above it you know and i think
more and more people are starting to
figure that out and and and the people
in their lives are like no my husband
my husband is a changed person no he's
not the same guy i know him i know he's
completely different and the guy is just
like yeah i feel amazing i feel great
and all it was was sitting in the fire
yes for a little bit of time until the
body finally moved out of the past into
the present moment and so
the causes of this like i always say you
never know
what you're doing today and how you're
doing it who you're going to affect
tomorrow when you do this work and
that's what we're seeing and people are
they're they're they're getting
promotions
uh they're getting all these wonderful
things not because
of anything that they're doing
they're just different yeah and people
notice that and they want those people
in the position to make better decisions
for the whole and i think that's uh
that's how we change the world in our
community at least people who have
relationships that are built uh from our
community
tend to be more long-lasting because
they're more self-aware and so there's
no blame there's no excuses there's no
make wrong there's no competition
there's none of that there's just this
is who i am you know and i think the
ultimate goal is
when you reach the point in your life
when how you appear to the world
is who you really are that level of
transparency is it takes no effort right
you can be yourself and and
and you know people say to me wow you're
pretty approachable and i say
well god i work so hard every day on
overcoming myself in the morning
overcoming my ego why would i want to
build it up the next day because i got
to face that guy again tomorrow morning
so why not just keep you know you know
taking those edges and smoothing them
down so that so that
you're you're less
unconscious to all of those programs
that are built in relationships people
that were traumatized
from childhood that were abused sexually
physically emotionally that were
suicidal that all kinds of health
conditions they came to the edge
of that emotion that kept them connected
to the past and they were ready to give
up in one meditation because
they they never had felt an emotion like
this that they could remember that it
was so intense
and they thought about all the times for
the last year that they never missed a
day of doing a meditation even when they
didn't feel like it or they wanted to
quit halfway through and they didn't
they went all the way they thought about
all those times
that they went to that point and they
went one more time really and their
words are always the same
and my heart blew wide open
and i look back at my entire past and i
don't want to change one thing in my
past because it brought me to this
present moment and i can see my
betrayers
i could
see the people in my life
that had a hand in this and i have
nothing but compassion for them because
now the person is no longer viewing that
path from the same level of
consciousness they're viewing it from a
place of love of wholeness and they see
the greater good of all of it and now
their their
their their conditions their health
conditions their endometriosis their
uterine tumors i mean whatever it is
literally
goes disappears and they have an
incredible incredible change in their
brain chemistry they're in love with
life they're off their meds they're not
suicidal they're why would they be
they're free
so it can happen in an instant when the
heart is healed and everybody gets the
new signal the body's out of the past
the body's no longer feeling the
emotions of the past and sometimes
we got to come right up against that
edge that's yeah that's the great moment
if you have been an experienced
uh if you had experience of trauma say
for example and it's created the feeling
of fear and your fear is that it could
happen again
and you're you don't know this but every
time you think about that future that
possible worst case scenario scenario
and you feel the emotion you're
conditioning your body to become the
mind subconsciously of anxiety
so now
all you need now is some cue in your
outer environment that says it's unsafe
that if there's damage there that you're
you're a victim something's bigger than
you that could have an effect on you
well now that feeling of fear
is going to cause you to think thoughts
equal to it
so the person then
no longer needs the environment
to feel that fear they just have to have
the thought about
that condition now and now they're
literally knocking their brain and body
out of balance by thought alone and the
body's constantly living in emergency
mode and it takes a lot of energy
a lot of resources to live in emergency
mode all the time
guess what system becomes compromised by
the immune system your immune system why
because you have two protection systems
you gotta get a system that protects you
from dangers in your outer world that's
that's the gas pedal that's the
sympathetic nervous system that's a
fight-or-flight nervous system danger
threat out there use all the energy
because you gotta you gotta survive and
when you survive you gotta take care of
your body so right so so now
that system can work really well short
term
it doesn't work really well if you keep
it on all the time because if you're
mobilizing all that energy for some
threat in your outer world there's no
energy in your inner world for growth
and repair there's no energy for
long-term building projects and energy
leaves the brain and it leaves the heart
and it moves into these lower centers
because now you're tapping the body's
resources because there is an emergency
but whether the emergency is real or
imagined
whether your anger is valid or justified
or not
that the you're tapping the body's very
energy to heal by doing this and the
immune system says well we're part of
really the other nervous system we're
the break we're the clutch
we need the we need to get into
relaxation we need to get back into
balance again and and when we do then
we'll metabolize then we'll we'll
assimilate we'll reproduce we'll
excrete properly so
so now you got a this kind of battle
between the gas pedal and the brake and
the immune system says hey listen if
there's foreign agents if there's
viruses bacteria molds funguses listen
we don't have a whole lot of energy here
to deal with them because we're fighting
this war out there there's no homeland
security so they shut down
certain receptors in the immune system
they shut down function
of those lymphocytes those white blood
cells that are your inner army of
protection and it takes a lot of energy
to fight a virus in a bacteria but if
there's no energy hey listen it takes
energy to raise the body's temperature
where do you think that comes from
that's part of that branch called the
autonomic nervous system and the
sympathetic the gas pedal is part of it
and the parasympathetic is the clutch is
part of that autonomic nervous system
and it's a check and balance but so you
stay in emergency for an extended period
of time
and now you're exposed to some
antigen or some
external substance some foreign agent i
will never work in a relationship i just
won't if i'm working in a relationship
something's wrong i'll work on me
i'll bring my best you bring your best
and we get together and we celebrate it
should work it should work and if it
doesn't then i'm going to step back and
see what is it about me not you what is
it about me that i need to really look
at and change now
if there's a vibrational match and it
flows and it's fun and you connect on
physically mentally mind body soul you
know that's cool i think that's healthy
but a permission-driven person can't be
in a relationship
where you have to keep going back
and and and trying to fix something i
just i just won't do that i just think
that when it when it's right it's right
and i'll know
yeah yeah so i think that i do think
that uh
relationships uh can be easy
and i i do think i i and i think that
they should be
and i and i think that if you're heart
centered
that's a different place you meet
uh than than uh other emotions and
and and i and again every time i have a
mystical moment
and i feel that
transcendental love that i don't even
know the word for uh every time i have
one of those moments i think i got this
all wrong it's just that it it's it is
not chemical it's electric and you got
what all wrong
well the way we view the world the way
we i mean we don't see things how they
are we see things how we are you know
and every inner experience that's
transcendental experience enriches
circuitry in your brain experience
produces
emotion or energy in the body so you
start having transcendental moments
where you start connecting to that field
its signature is love i mean but not
love like a love for your puppy
it's this is like this is like an
arousal this is i don't know the other
word but spiritual arousal yeah and we
have the we have the evidence we can say
oh watch this watch this person's brain
and scientists are studying our work
i'll say oh um watch she's going to pop
in a few minutes what do you mean just
watch she's going to pop and all of a
sudden this person goes into an arousal
the sympathetic nervous system is so
switched on but the arousal isn't like
an arousal that from the environment
that produces anger or aggression or
fear anxiety or pain or suffering that's
survival in the environment that
produces the arousal this arousal is
coming from energy in the body that's
moving up into the brain and
the arousal is bliss arousal is ecstasy
the arousal is freedom
but it's it's it's not chemical it's
it's you'll feel it in every single cell
in your body now here's the outcome of
that
the outcome of that is that when you
open your eyes
and some conditioning some layer has
been removed
your spectrum of the way the world looks
broadens now because now you're wired to
perceive what's always existed
but you didn't have the circuits in
place to perceive them so then it's the
inner experience that literally trans
transforms our experience of the outer
world and so
when you start having moments where you
hit that kind of frequency or you have
those moments of love
you're less dependent on anyone to bring
you happiness you're you're okay you can
love the person for their flaws
because you can see a part of yourself
you used to be that you no longer aren't
instead of judgment you have compassion
and you can encourage and and and
communicate from from a level of
connection instead of intimidation or or
competition or however relationships
works what are the three things we
should say when we wake up in the
morning or think
well first i would say
what is the greatest ideal of myself
that i can be today
and i would not get up until i felt like
that person
the second thing i would say is can i
begin to keep my energy up the entire
day and if i do it properly then i will
be open to opportunities and
possibilities that weren't there before
the last thing i would say is could i
sustain
brain and heart coherence to the point
where that intelligence within me that's
giving me life begins to find the door
to open out so i can begin to see
evidence in my world what would you say
every evening before you go to sleep oh
yeah how did i do that how did i do how
did i do how did i do today i mean one
day one lifetime yeah how did i do today
did i change or help another human being
did i really change someone's future
future timeline lastly what is the
greatest thing i learned
overcoming the old self allows us to
become somebody else and there is that
period of transition yeah i call it the
void where there's just not a lot
happening
and you just got to be able yeah to keep
going and continuously get to the end of
your belief where most people stop i
just had a fabulous conversation with
someone uh this weekend
broke through to the other side
and now there's so much magic happening
around this person
but she's worthy now
to receive it and that's that
that is the key because the universe
only gives us what we think we're worthy
of receiving so we gotta become
initiated into this and understand it
thousands of years of programming that
says that we have to change things uh
matter to matter you know in
three-dimensional reality and it will
take time but
to begin to connect to that resource
called the quantum field and create from
the field instead of from matter
there's a lot of unlearning that has to
go on i think this is a time in history
where it's not enough to know this is
the time in history to know how
and
if you rewind the tape 10 years ago you
know information was the thing that
stimulated thought stimulated new ideas
and and as we learn new things we make
new connections in our brains so
as we begin to add new stitches into
that three-dimensional tapestry in our
mind
we're beginning to cause our mind to
function in new ways but the key then
is to apply it to personalize it to do
something with it in in ten years ago
when i went got in front of an audience
and talked about the application
nobody wanted to step outside that
philosophical theoretical intellectual
realm right because doing something
means you're gonna have to change
something about yourself
yeah you're gonna get uncomfortable
right
and um
i think we're in an age of information
and in an age of information ignorance
is a choice and because of technology we
have access to so much content
and information creates awareness and
awareness is consciousness and you can't
have consciousness without energy there
they work together so there's an
energetic change i think that's taking
place in the world right now where
people are so informed
that old models old paradigms are
beginning to break down whether it's the
medical model or the religious model the
education model journalism
the economy you know
politics it's all beginning to
come to the surface because something
else has to come out and and i think
that one of the things that people are
realizing is that you don't have to be a
buddhist monk to do this or a nun with
40 years of devotion you just got to
understand the formula and just like any
skill or anything you learn
you got to go from thinking to doing to
being you got to take knowledge you
create the experience and if you keep
doing it over and over again you start
getting a skill or you start getting
wise about how to do it and you you know
that you know how to do it you have to
really begin to
mentally rehearse like so you ask
yourself at the end of your day i do
this every day how'd i do
how'd i do today bro how'd you do did
you do good where'd you fall from grace
what what what was it
that caused you to go unconscious
for the rest of the day like what was
that moment now if you're a student
of life
you'll begin to contemplate well it was
that person that said that thing then i
reacted or this i got this email or
things didn't go my way and i started
feeling angry or frustrated or fearful
the next time that happens
how could i evolve my experience now you
may have to search for some answers
of the best model to build or you may
actually have a long contemplation and
start to go god the next time that
happens i think i'm going to do this or
i'm going to do that or i'm going to
plan my behaviors
and the act of closing your eyes
and rehearsing what you're going to do
begins to install the neurological
hardware in your brain to look like you
already did it now the brain is no
longer a record of the past now it's a
map to the future and if you keep
installing that hardware the hardware
will become a software program which
means you'll just start acting like a
happy person why there's no magic there
you install the circuitry so
that's more important
than the news right it's more important
than answering any email or any text
it's more important than talking about
your past or some dinner
if you can begin to just
think about how you're going to do it
differently
that's the building process
neurologically already so now you have
to get conscious in order to do that and
it takes some time that means you got to
shut your cell phone off you got to
close your door you got to take a break
from everything out there
and begin to practice and so
by experience then
you start noticing oh here it comes here
comes the frustration here comes the
fear
and now we've given people the tools to
be able to self-regulate to create brain
and heart coherence and so you see
people say excuse me one minute i just
need a minute
it takes some breaths they get back in
they connect to the energy of their
future this is incidental compared to
where they're going so they don't
fall from grace they don't allow their
energy to drop and so yeah in the
beginning
it takes a lot because it takes a lot of
energy and awareness
to stay conscious and not go unconscious
but if you're persistent and you're
determined then you're sincere
you begin to figure it out you begin to
say
i am not going to give my power away to
that person or that circumstance when i
can use it to heal or to create a new
future and so people then
won't excuse themselves and say on a
hard day yesterday at a fight with my
co-worker or my ex or and i don't feel
like doing the work well
that's the time to get back on the horse
yeah because because
it's the it's all of those times that we
self-correct
those are the most valuable moments to
us people who've had
profoundly transcendental experiences
where they
we say got lit up they connected and
their brain goes into very very high
coherent states and super gamma patterns
that are way outside of normal and they
have a transcendental download or
connection that's mystical
they look back at their entire life
they don't want to change one thing in
their past
because it got them to that moment
that's the moment the past no longer
exists now by the same means
they look back at their past and they
see all those tough moments
where they overcame themselves and they
fall in love with that person they don't
look at the good meditations or the
things that went well
they look they know that it was those
moments that got them to this moment and
i think then
that's when they begin to understand
that that all of the hard work
all the effort
in who we become makes no one can take
that away from us so then once we arrive
at that level and we experience whatever
the dream is or whatever we create the
next thing is do it until you fully
enjoy it and then when it gets boring or
predictable let's go again let's do
something else our research shows that
when you get a community of people
together
and they begin to open their hearts and
they they have the intent for the
greatest good for people that they know
or people that they could focus on
that our research shows that you can
actually affect another person's
autonomic nervous system when you move
into hard coherence in a very non-local
way well what's the significance of that
well we have an amazing community
and our community is connected by these
elevated emotions those other emotions
of survival create separation but we we
work to open our hearts and to feel
connected we can begin to affect people
in a very non-local way
in other words everybody else's hearts
go into coherence at the exact same time
you by opening your heart
strengthen your connection to this
community you strengthen the connection
to the people that you relate with in
your lives when you move into that state
you you begin to affect everybody else
the majority of our thoughts and
feelings
are connected to our sexuality
to our victimization our guilt our
suffering our shame our unworthiness our
self-doubt or our importance our control
our fear our anger our frustration our
hatred our judgment those are those are
the first three hormonal centers in the
body and and those first three centers
have everything to do with survival and
those centers are energy consumers
orgasm digestion
stress
is a lot of energy that we're drawing
from our very vital life force yes a
resource of light and information and
we're turning it into chemistry and
we're literally robbing the body's
energy right so so then living like that
for the short term is okay because the
body can move back to homeostasis and
restore itself but
when we're over doing that consistently
then there's no energy for growth and
repair because you're living constantly
in survival so
again you can eat all the right food you
can do all the right things but if
you're living in anxiety and fear and
you're viewing your world from the worst
case scenario that could possibly happen
because that's what you do in survival
there's no energy for growth and repair
there's no energy for healing so the
majority of our thoughts
are signaling certain circuits in the
brain that signal another part of the
brain limbic brain to make what's called
a neuropeptide neuropeptides are
chemical messengers that signal hormonal
centers so now you're taking thought
and you're storing it as energy in these
energy centers and and if you're living
in survival why would you open your
heart i mean it's just not a time to
open your heart i mean if you're getting
chased by t-rex
it's not a time to meditate it's not a
time to learn it's not a time to connect
it's not a time to communicate it's not
a time to sit down and go within it's
not a time to be vulnerable it's time to
run fight or hide and so is that why
we're this way i've never asked you this
before is this some
uh i don't i don't think you believe
this but i just want to understand is
this some sort of genetic disposition
that's been passed down to us since
we've been chased by t-rex i think so i
think survival has been very adaptive
yeah like because if you're being chased
by t-rex you don't run up to t t-rex and
say oh cute little dinosaur let me pet
you that's not adaptive the fear is
adaptive you run from the unknown you
run from challenges right yes so if
you're living in survival there's better
chances of surviving
if you run from the unknown and by the
way when you're living in survival at
the infinite potentials in the quantum
field
you'll select the worst case scenario in
your mind and you'll begin to
emotionally prepare yourself for the
worst case scenario because you have
better chances of surviving there you go
if you prepare for the worst right so
people spend their whole life yes
thinking about the worst thing and
emotionally embracing it while you take
a thought and emotion or an image and an
emotion you're branding or conditioning
your body into what anxiety
into fear so then you keep doing that
over and over again over and over again
your the body becomes the mind of fear
and whether you think you can control it
or not you're gonna have a panic attack
and the panic attack is the body saying
you've conditioned me this way try as
you may with your conscious mind and
control it right you programmed it
subconsciously then you start worrying
about the next panic attack and it's
that very anticipation there we go keeps
the person on the hamster wheel it robs
them of all of this energy as well
they're absolutely so so so they don't
believe
in possibility when they're living in
that state because in survival it's not
a time to create all the blood flow is
going to the hind brain and away from
the forebrain there's no there's there's
no physiology really for a person to
begin to create a new future so then so
think about it so then
70 of the time people in the world are
living anticipating the next moment
based on their past moment and so
they're laying reality down moment by
moment with the next known the next
predictable moment and so the hormones
of stress endorse the senses our senses
become heightened when we're under
stress
and we become materialists we narrow our
focus on the danger yes so then you're
focusing on matter you're focusing on
the material world and when you do that
you put all your attention the arousal
of the stress hormones puts all your
attention on your body if you're being
chased by t-rex you better be paying
attention to your body so then if you're
sitting in a meditation and your body's
thrown the kitchen sink at you and
saying ed you're a loser you're never
going to change this is too hard why
don't you quit and you're aware that
that's your body doing that and you say
to your body
we're gonna sit here
and we're gonna sit in this fire and i'm
gonna keep applying the formula and my
your brain starts running to all the
emails you have to do and you become
aware of that and return back to the
present moment and you tell the body
it's no longer the mind that you're the
mind now your will is getting greater
than that program and there's a
liberation of energy and every time you
do that that's a victory
and you teach every time you do that
that's a victory when your mind tells
the body i'm in charge when you say
you're when you you just want to get up
and you want to quit and you go
no that's my body bring it back okay and
now you're now you're taming the animal
the body is the animal and you're like a
dog you sit
and if you keep doing this keep doing
this you're climbing on top and the body
finally acquiesces it finally says i'm
not going anywhere and then boom there's
this liberation of energy what's the
side effect
joy
person's heart just automatically opens
up and and every time they do that those
victories add up there's no such thing
as a bad meditation there's only
overcoming yourself
and when you sit in the fire
and you work with that people say to me
why do you meditate every morning i say
because if i can overcome myself in the
morning the rest of my day is easy it's
easy true because because that's what
it's about you master yourself you
master your life yes and so then all the
chatter in your head that you listen to
all day long that is called the default
mode network in the brain our research
shows
that shuts off not just shuts off during
the meditation it stays shut off for the
rest of the day so the critic in your
head that's telling you this will never
happen you have enough time all right
that there's no voice there so you just
have a clear flow on where you're going
and you trust yourself more first of all
every time we have a thought we make a
chemical and and if you have
uh
an unlimited thought you will feel
unlimited and if you have a
self-depreciating thought you'll feel
unworthy and your brain instantaneously
fires circuits
that signal another part of the brain to
release peptides or chemical messengers
that signal hormonal centers
and when we get that arousal from the
thought that we think
those thoughts sometimes weaken the
response weakens the physical body so
it turns out that
the emotions that are created from the
thoughts are the signaling mechanisms of
the body thoughts of the language of the
brain
and feelings are the language of the
body and how we think and how we feel
creates our state of being
so it turns out that the thoughts based
in the stress hormones based in survival
those are the thoughts that begin to
push the genetic buttons that create
disease in other words
a person wakes up in the morning
and the brain is a record of the past
the first thing they do when they wake
up in the morning is they start thinking
about their problems
and those problems are memories that are
etched in the brain that are connected
to certain people certain objects
certain things at certain times and
places so if you believe that your
thoughts have something to do with your
destiny the moment you think about your
problems you're thinking in the past
right
now every one of those problems has an
emotion associated with them because
we've experienced them so the moment you
remember your problems
now you feel unhappy now you feel
anxious now you feel fear
so the moment we feel those emotions it
takes a thought and a feeling
a memory or an image an emotion
a stimulus and a response and we start
conditioning the body emotionally into
the past now the body
is so objective
that it doesn't know the difference
between the real life experience that's
creating that emotion
and the emotion that person's
fabricating by thought alone the body's
believing it's in that environmental
condition
so if the environment signals the gene
and that's the truth
and the end product of an experiences in
the environment is an emotion
we're signaling the same genes and genes
make proteins and if you keep signaling
the same genes you start down regulating
the gene to make cheaper proteins and
the body begins to break down now that's
an unconscious process
so what goes along with that is the
moment the person feels that emotion of
unhappiness or whatever it is
uh the brain checks in with the body and
says yeah you're feeling pretty
miserable you're suffering and we tend
to generate more thoughts
equal to the feeling that we have
and so then we get caught in this loop
of thinking and feeling so if we can't
think
greater than how we feel
our feelings have become the means of
thinking
then we're thinking in the past if the
person's doing the vision board and
they're saying when i get my new car i
get my new house i get my new
relationship
then i'm gonna feel so great
now that well then they're back to the
program waiting for it to happen
for them to feel the emotion they're
believing their outer world has to
change in order for them to feel better
there's there's no
effect of drawing the experience to you
with that way
so
the person has to use those tools
to get them into the emotional state
for them to feel like it's already
happened now think about this
if you get up from
a creative process
and you feel grateful
you feel a love for life you feel a joy
for existence
you feel a passion
uh
to
for the moment
uh
you will not be looking for your future
because you'll feel like it's already
happened
it's the moment that we start feeling
those self-limiting emotions that we
feel separation and then we start
looking for it again well then if you're
waiting you're not creating you're
you're in separation again so then yeah
so then
whatever it takes for you to move into a
state of being and what is a state of
being
thoughts are the vocabulary of the brain
feelings are the vocabulary of your body
how you think and how you feel creates
your state of being so then if you wake
up in the morning and you
come come back to your senses with a
clean slate and you say i don't feel
anything you say well let me start
thinking about all the problems in my
life well all those problems are
connected to different people or
different objects of things at different
times and places the moment you remember
your problems a memory is a record of
the past you're thinking in the past
every one of those problems has an
emotion associated with them so all of a
sudden you start feeling unhappy you
start feeling bitter you start feeling
frustrated so now your body's in the
past so then most people then
create a state of being that's connected
to their past and if they're in the
familiar past
then they are going to crave the
predictable future and they're going to
fall back into routine
so then
we want people then to get very clear on
that vision of their future however they
do it and begin to combine that clear
intention with an elevated emotion and
the stronger the emotion they feel
from the vision they're creating the
more altered they feel inside of them
the more they're going to pay attention
to the pictures in their mind and now
they're remembering their future and
biologically it's exactly the same as
remembering your past in fact if you're
not being defined by a vision in the
future it means you're making your past
more real than your future you're
falling in love with your past you're
more in love with your past than you are
with your future that you're believing
in your past more than you're believing
in your future when you get to that
moment
where you have that feeling
that's your compass
because that feeling is going to drive
your behaviors it's going to drive more
of those thoughts and when you feel that
feeling and it's visceral
no person
no thing no experience will stand in the
way between you and that vision and and
you will be initiated in by the universe
into wealth you will be initiated into
health you'll be initiated into freedom
those people all those people that have
healed themselves of all those different
health conditions
they are so humble
and so happy and they feel so great
that they would never trade this feeling
because of what you thought of them they
they've they've left that program behind
a long time ago they actually don't care
how you think of them they they actually
are so happy with themselves
that they are no longer dependent on
anything outside of them now i think
that's a really important moment because
that's the moment we give people
permission in our lives to do the same
right and i think that more and more
people are beginning to figure that out
uh as they do this work one of the
things about the global pandemic that i
said to my staff and to my family the
moment i heard how the circumstances in
the world changed
i just said i refused to be a victim
to these circumstances so a victim
consciousness is when
we allow something in our outer
environment to control the way we feel
and think so i say to you jay why are
you so upset today and you said oh it's
because of this person or circumstance
what you're really saying is something
in my outer environment some person or
some condition is controlling the way i
think and feel and that's not the truth
that's just a response right
so anything that controls our thoughts
and feelings causes us to be victim to
those things and the stronger the
emotion we feel to some circumstance in
our life the more we pay attention to it
and where we place our attention is
where we place our energy so
we're giving our life force we're giving
our power away to that circumstance and
so i just made up my mind that
it was a great opportunity to get into
the cocoon if we teach a person then how
to trade that frustration or that hatred
for an elevated emotion and they'll say
yeah but you know it was my ex's fault
or i got betrayed by my partner in
business yeah yeah yeah we know that
okay so let's take your partner in
business or take your ex let's duct tape
them put them in a cannon and shoot them
to the moon now what are you going to do
sooner or later you got to reckon with
yourself and change right so then
teach a person then how to trade that
emotion for an elevated emotion now
trade the emotion for an elevated
emotion right so you're going to give
that up and you're going to practice
feeling gratitude for as an example yes
the person says well i can't feel
gratitude and i say absolutely you can
because you don't practice feeling it
you practice spending most of your time
feeling hatred and frustration so now
it's going to take a little time to
cause that heart of you to bloom or your
heart of yours to bloom once they're
able to feel even the smallest measure
of gratitude where they start feeling
appreciation
thankfulness
gratitude it's emotional signature when
you when you get something
when you're receiving something
when something has happened to you
or when something is happening to you
you say thank you because you're
receiving something so the emotional
signature
of gratitude means the event has already
happened where it's happening to you so
the moment you open your heart and you
feel gratitude well that emotion then is
telling the body that the experience has
already occurred and the thought then
can make it into the body because it's
consistent with the thought so now
you're beginning to program the
autonomic nervous system into a very
specific destiny and you've got to
maintain that modified state of mind and
body your entire day independent of the
conditions in your outer environment
independent of your body's cravings of
those emotions and habituations and
independent from time and if you can
get ready because something weird or
unusual some synchronicity some
coincidence some opportunity is going to
land in your lap and you didn't have to
go and get it yes it came to you now
you're the vortex of creation so if you
say to me well i was feeling gratitude
but then there was traffic or my
co-worker sent me a
nasty email then i would say oh my god
you mean you're allowing your
environment your outer environment to
control how you feel and think
you're back to the unconscious program
that you're the victim to your life you
got it but when you start producing
those outcomes in your life you're going
to pay attention to what you did inside
of you and you're going to believe more
that you're the creator of your life and
less of the victim of your life turns
out we've done an experiment just 10
minutes a day
three times a day with 120 people
trading resentment frustration fear for
gratitude appreciation and thankfulness
measuring their immune response
the the chemical immunoglobulin a your
primary defense against bacteria and
viruses the best flu shot you'll ever
get lives innately within you turns out
when you're frustrated when you're
impatient when you're fearful the immune
system dials down because you're an
emergency it's not it's all your energy
is going for some threat in your outer
world there's no energy in your inner
world for growth and repair but how do
you turn that around so then as people
begin to open their heart
can that chemical begin
to to
elevate
four days
50
change in the 120 people their their iga
levels went up 50 in four days that's
your body's immune system is now
upregulating genes that are making
proteins and immunoglobulins and
antibodies that you don't need a flu
shot in other words your inner state is
greater than your outer world so then
just by doing that we now know that your
immune system is going to get stronger
by the same means
take 120 people or 50 people and measure
7500 gene regulations
okay
in four days two genes that suppress
cancer growth and tumors are activated
and up regulated the genes that
stimulate stem cells that go to damaged
tissues and repair them up regulate them
the gene for oxidative balance is
upregulated anti-cancer anti-aging
anti-heart disease anti-stroke
anti-neurodegenerative anti-inflammatory
antimicrobial just your body is
naturally doing this
the gene for neurogenesis
the growth of new neurons in response to
novel experiences and learning this is
four days the gene switches on
uh the the gene for more balance in the
pituitary and the pancreas the gene for
the microtubules of the cells the the
little little fibers that respond to
energy and frequency so in four days we
now know that you can change your
genetic destiny
if you just practice the inner work if
you think about this your senses plug
you into your external environment
everything you're seeing or smelling or
tasting or feeling or hearing all of
your five senses are affecting your
brain
so if you're waking up in the morning
and you're going through the same
routine behaviors as you did the day
before
and you're not in the process of being
defined by a vision of the future
then you're for the most part left with
the old hardware in your brain from the
past as a matter of fact your brain is
organized to reflect everything you know
from the past
so as people wake up and they begin to
pay attention to their body they start
to look around in their environment they
start to do typical things
it's the external environment that's
turning on different circuits in their
brain causing them to think equal to
their environment
and if you have the idea that your
thoughts have something to do with your
destiny as long as you're thinking equal
to your environment you keep creating
the same reality over and over again so
to change is to think greater than your
environment to think greater than the
circumstances in your world to think
greater than the conditions in your life
and i think every great person in
history understood this they were
defined by a vision that was much bigger
than that we have research to show that
60 days of meditation
five days a week will lengthen your life
the telomeres the little shoestrings on
the end of your dna get longer that
means your biological age is changing so
we we have the evidence now
to show people what's possible we have
brain scans that that are so outside of
normal that when neuroscientists see
them they're blown away because the
amount of energy that's in the brain
during this transcendental moment is uh
hundreds of times outside of normal wow
i mean you can't make your brain do that
something is happening to you and that
person's having a transcendental moment
and we now know that we can predict it
and we now know that we can induce it so
then there's the evidence there i think
uh you know if we everything starts with
a thought i mean everything that you do
in your life you you have to have a
thought before you initiate an action
right so
so if you believe that your thoughts
have something to do with your destiny
like any great leader in history
understands that
the first thing you have to do is you
have to decide are you going to be
defined by a vision of the future
or are you going to live by the memories
of the past so give you an example
most people wake up in the morning
and your brain is a record of the past
it's an artifact of everything you've
learned and experienced to this moment
right it's a it's a memory bank
so most people wake up in the morning
and they start thinking about their
problems and those problems are
connected to certain people and things
at certain times and places
and the moment they start start turning
on those circuits those memories are
actually causing them to think in the
past
every single one of those memories has
an emotion associated with them and
emotions are the end product of past
experiences
so then the moment they recall the event
or the they recall some problem in their
life they start feeling unhappy they
start feeling discouraged they start
feeling anxious now thoughts of the
language of the brain and feelings of
the language of the body and how you
think and how you feel creates your
state of being so we could say then
most people's entire state of being when
they start their day is in the familiar
past well if you live in the familiar
past then it makes sense you're going to
create the predictable future so what
happens for most people is they get
stuck in their biology so think about
this
your body is your unconscious mind it
doesn't know the difference between an
experience in your life that creates an
emotion and an emotion that you can
create by thought alone so if you're
living by the same emotion every single
day and those emotions are influencing
your thoughts
and you can't think greater than how you
feel or feelings have become the means
of thinking you're thinking in the past
your lens of the future is going to be
colored by the past so you can't see
possibilities so most people like to
wait for crisis or disease or diagnosis
before they wake up enough to see well
the challenge is is that biology tends
to be redundant so
if you keep thinking the same thoughts
and those thoughts begin to fire certain
circuits in your brain the nerve cells
that fire together wire together so all
of a sudden you start getting hardwired
and those are the thoughts that you can
think the easiest at the same time those
thoughts produce chemicals called
emotions and the next thing you know
your body gets accustomed to living by
the same emotions and it could be guilt
it could be unhappiness it could be pain
but at least it's familiar to you at
least you can predict it so some people
would rather cling to the familiar than
take a chance in possibility so
for most people then they say well
i don't really see how my thoughts have
anything to do with my destiny well
that's because
95 of those thoughts are subconscious
programs right so you're not even
conscious that you think those thoughts
so the first step to change
is starting to think about what you've
been thinking about and change it and
and then when you begin to observe those
thoughts you're no longer the program
you're the consciousness observing just
simply by being an observer of your
thoughts right so so though so most
people though when they when you do that
when you decide to really take a look
it's like lighting a match in a dark
place
so you feel uncomfortable so it's easier
to turn on your tv it's easier to
play with your cell phone to distract
yourself from those feelings well when
you understand that change really
requires becoming uncomfortable to a
certain degree and that's normal that
you're leaving the known and you're
stepping into the unknown
then it begs the question what thoughts
do you want to fire and wire in your
brain because your attention on those
thoughts begins to reorganize circuitry
we re-mold the brain so then when you're
feeling gratitude and your heart is open
you're broadcasting energy into the
field frequency the frequency you lay
the intent of the thought of your health
or your wealth that frequency can carry
the thought of your wealth it can carry
the thought of your health if you're
suffering
you can't suffering does not carry that
energy does not carry the thought of
your wealth it carries a different set
of thoughts so then so then we're
teaching people
how to self-regulate because if you're
going to believe in that future that
you're imagining with all of your heart
it better be open and activated right
and you better know how to self-regulate
and you have to know the moment you
disconnect from the energy of your
future because of some circumstance in
your life and you lose that feeling
if you're practicing it on a daily basis
with your eyes closed then the next
level is to be able to open your eyes
and do it right in the moment and be
able to self-regulate and change
the the frustration from some experience
in your life back to the energy of your
future now
that requires great awareness and great
effort but if you have a community of
people
that are practicing this on a daily
basis and they're connected to their
future because that's where their their
mind is
they begin to want the future
more than the emotions of the past so
we've done enough measurements now lewis
to know that we can teach people how to
do that and we have evidence that people
can sustain it
for 45 minutes to an hour it's a skill
now they know that they know how to do
it so now they have brain coherence and
heart coherence well once the heart
begins to become orderly and coherent it
acts as an amplifier and it drives
energy to the brain so now the brain is
getting more energy once the heart is
open and then you're thinking different
set of thoughts and those thoughts
produce different chemicals for you to
feel more of that and here comes
uh nitric oxide from oxytocin and then
all of a sudden your heart literally
starts to swell it literally begins to
open up and there's more energy going
there and now you're coming from a
different level of mind i think one of
the challenges i think many people have
is really the discernment of information
it's really difficult to know what's the
truth anymore just because
information is so accessible and i used
to say that in an age of information
ignorance is a choice and and now we
have to confront a whole nother level
and that is
the information that we're getting uh is
it is it actually supporting us or is it
something that really is an incentive to
to cause us to make choices so um for me
i think the biggest challenge has been
just really an awakening to
what kind of information i want to
expose myself to and i and i think it's
now more than ever a challenge for a lot
of people in the world we have research
to show that 60 days of meditation
five days a week
will lengthen your life the telomeres
the little shoestrings on the end of
your dna get longer that means your
biological age is changing
so we we have the evidence now
to show people what's possible we have
brain scans that that are so outside of
normal that when neuroscientists see
them they're blown away because the
amount of energy that's in the brain
during this transcendental moment is uh
hundreds of times outside of normal wow
i mean you can't make your brain do that
something is happening to you and that
person's
having a transcendental moment and we
now know that we can predict it and we
now know that we can induce it so then
there's the evidence there
then you take
our community and you see people with
stage four cancer with parkinson's
disease with myasthenia gravis with
with lupus with ms with
brain injuries
with rare genetic disorders with vertigo
tinnitus
kidney failure all kinds of health
conditions come to a week-long event
and then at the end of that event
they make significant strides in getting
beyond the emotions of the past now
think about this
the science says that the environment
signals the gene that's epigenetics
the end product of an experience in the
environment is an emotion so as long as
you're living by the same emotion every
single day you're signaling the same
gene in the same way and if that gene is
related to a survival emotion a stress
hormone then you're down regulating the
gene and you're creating disease so when
the person trades that emotion and
really breaks free from the chains of
their past
and now they're feeling an elevated
emotion
well now they're dialing down the gene
for ms and they're up regulating the
gene for health and balance and so the
person will you'll say to them where's
the disease well i'm not the same person
i'm not and and the side effect
of that is a transformation in healing
so
the funny thing about it is the person
who has the healing is not talking about
the healing
whether it's blind people seeing deaf
people hearing hearing we have crazy
evidence now
what they're talking about is how
amazing they feel
because
they're refreshed they're they're they
got a new lease on life and so now we
have evidence
in our research
and that silence is the critic to show
that what's possible for people i'm
starting to realize how conditioned we
are into believing how limited we are
and as you start peeling those layers
away and you break through those beliefs
those self-limiting thoughts and
emotions
on the other side of that is where the
miraculous happens so you got to be
willing to be in that place of
discomfort long enough to reorganize
order and begin to create more coherence
and then all of a sudden you get this
recalibration that goes on in the brain
and body and then the extent of that is
that
the ultimate thing is you start to see
feedback in your life those
synchronicities those coincidences those
opportunities you're scratching your
head going
everything is falling into place yeah
i'm in the right place at the right time
i think about just comes to me because
your energy is synchronized it's
look i mean
when you have coherence in the brain and
heart you have a laser of energy and it
could read information much better
you're living in stress and your brain
is shifting its attention from one
person to another problem to another
thing to another
place to go
each one of those things there's an
assignment of neurological networks in
the brain so the arousal of the stress
hormones drives the brain into this high
frequency and you're trying to control
and predict everything in your life and
those your brain circuits are firing
like a like a lightning storm in the
clouds when your brain's incoherent
you're incoherent and and you can't you
don't have a signal you're you don't
have a wi-fi signal not connected to the
field how could you how could you
connect to energy and information if
your signal hasn't become orderly so
that when people synchronize their
energy into coherence they can
synchronize to a possibility in the
future in the synchronicities
that are feedback from the environment
are just a reflection of your energy
and that's the universe saying
follow the breadcrumbs do it again
follow it again do it again and now all
of a sudden the person's not waking up
in the morning like oh
i got to meditate now to create my
future they're kind of going like i'm
getting out of bed because i don't want
the magic to end right they want to they
want to sustain that state so that
the old
reality that they've lived in begins to
transform into something new and because
there's no longer a vibrational match
with everyone and everything in their
past present reality there's a
vibrational match to their future and
now their future is starting to give
them signals
because you made it this far in a video
i want to celebrate you most people
start and don't finish most people never
actually follow through most people say
they want something but they don't ever
do the work to actually get it but
you're different you are special believe
nation you made it here all the way to
the end and i love you so it's a special
celebration if you put a hashtag believe
down in the comments below on this video
i will showcase you and celebrate you
somewhere on the screen in a future
video because
you are awesome if you want some
incredible bruce lipton motivation check
the video right there next to me
continue to believe and i'll see you
there i don't care how much knowledge is
in your head if that knowledge doesn't
go into your subconscious your life will
stay exactly the same as it was you can
be the brightest smartest academic and i
say fine did it change your life and the
answer is no